[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
הייתי בשלושה טיפולים, שלוש שנים ברוח אחרת. עכשיו אני מתרגל יותר.
לא לא לא, אני רק נראה לי כבר מפגר, לא?
אני יודע שיש מישהו שלוקח סמסטר שלם.
עכשיו התרגיל בסדר. בשביל זה בסדר. צריך להיות מתרגל בשביל שיגידו לנו בסדר או לא, אתה מבטיח שזה לא קשה.
מחזיק את השיעור. אני אומר לך זה לא עזר. לא, לא, זה ככה, זה בסדר.
זה לא זה לא. הוא לא עסוק, לא עושה את העבודה שלו שם. כאילו אוקיי.
כן כן כן, זה כן יוצא הרבה אני.
מאחל לך הצלחה במקום לפתור את הבעיה.
אבל זה לא היה פשוט. מצטער.
אבל בבניו המשתאות יכולה להיות אומה אחת. יש לך אחריות?
גמר חתימה טובה. צלילה ברשתות דברים שאתה לא רוצה זו בעיה.
וואי וואי אני רואה את זה כי הבן זונה צרפתייה אבל וויסקי?
צרפתי זה מה שאתם צריכים לעשות? דבר חשוב גם טיפה אחרת בסופו.
של דבר. ועל זה כתבתי בעבר, אבל גם במקרה של גרמניה מעניין אותי.
מסתבך הסכסוך. צרו קשר. תפריט.
אודות. צרו.
קשר. בשביל שזה. 4. מבחינה פיננסית הבחירה הכי חכמה שעשיתי את זה.
אז אפשר להגיד שכבר.
יצא? לי להיות.
אוקיי. שלום לכולם. שוב סליחה ולציבור אנחנו נמשיך היום את הדיון שלנו בנושא.
בואו נסיים את הדיון בנושא Transformers בנושא ארכיטקטורה. נדבר קצת על אבולוציה בהתחלה של Machine translation.
לקראת סוף השידור של Language Models ונדבר קצת על כל הרעיון של Self Training של Self Supervision ו training שאולי חלקכם שמעתם עליו ודאי חלק אחר לא שמע.
אז תקציר השיעור הקודם דיברנו על Machine Translation ובעצם הנקודה שבה הפסקנו הייתה שהצגנו את הארכיטקטורה של ה Transformer.
דיברנו בעיקר על Encoding ושם, פחות או יותר עצרנו.
אז בואו ניזכר. בואו ניזכר איפה היינו אז.
דבר ראשון. Self attention כן. מישהי או מישהו רוצים להסביר מה זה self attention?
כן, במקום להשתמש פתאום זה דיברנו על כולנו.
כאילו, בין אם בין אקשן לחיילים אקשן.
אתה לא צריך את ההקשר. מאפשרת למילים לשמוע את מה שנראה מיינסטרים רגיל.
אחר כך כל אחת חושבת מה היא רוצה לקחת. אוקיי, אחלה שיטה ומעולה ובאופן קצת יותר פורמלי.
יש לך טיפ ישראלי? כן, בדיוק.
אוקיי, אז בעצם הצורה שבה אתה משתמש בהם?
אם אתה מאומן להיות מה שאמרתי. כן.
בדיוק. אז אתה נותן לו נגיד את הדוגמה של מייק. נכון? או מייקינג?
אז נגיד במשפט הזה זה מייקינג איקס more difficult.
נכון, יש כאן משהו שאולי בתרגום אנחנו נרצה לתרגם את כל השלישייה הלא רצופה הזאת במשפט למילה אחת.
נכון שהיא מבקשת נגיד בעברית נכון להקשות?
בדיוק. ולעומת זאת, אם היה לנו מייקינג בהקשרים אחרים אז אולי לא היינו רוצים לתרגם את זה להקשות אלא להכין, להפוך.
Whatever. כן, או לפעמים אפילו דברים כמו לפשל או לעשות משהו בצורה שלומיאלית כמו הדוגמה שנתתי של המייקאפ Dogs Breakfast.
או. כן. או Turn. כן, משהו כזה שזה פשוט אומר לעשות ממנו בלאגן.
אז אם נשים לב, הדוגמה של Make a more difficult כן, בעצם יש לה.
לא רק שהיא בעצם כמה מילים לא רצופות שאולי היינו רוצים לייצג איכשהו כדבר אחד, נכון,
כי בעצם זה יחידה מקסיקנית אחת והיא מתרגמת בחלק מהשפות פשוט למילה אחת, אלא גם שיש לה מבנה פנימי.
נכון, ה more הזה מתייחס ל difficult. נכון, יש כאן more difficult זה דבר אחד.
או במייק אפ Dogs Breakfast? או אז יש dogs breakfast.
נכון, זה לא פשוט. מייק שמתחבר לדוג זה שם קודם איזשהו מושג שנקרא.
Dogs Breakfast, שבגדול אומר באנגלית בריטית בלאגן או משהו כזה?
כן. ואז הוא מתחבר למייק. אוקיי, אז בעצם יש כאן איזשהו מבנה פנימי.
למה אני אומר את זה? כי זה אולי גם קצת נותן לפחות איזושהי קצת אינטואיציה.
למה אנחנו רוצים לא לעשות פעם אחת את self tension ולעשות קומבינציה אחת של איזשהו מיקס.
פעם אחת של כמה עם Weddings לתוך עם Wedding, אחד שהוא קונטקסט שהוא List, אלא אולי גם אותם ללכת ולעשות להם עוד פעם self attention.
כן, עוד פעם איזה מיקס ואולי עוד פעם ועוד פעם ולבנות כמה שכבות.
כי יכול להיות שפעולות כמו למשל למצוא את נגיד, אפשר לחשוב על זה.
מושגים תחביריים, את הדיפנדר, את התחבירי? כן. מה ההד של איזושהי מילה?
אולי יחסית קל לעשות בעלים. אולי יחסית קל למצוא לתת עץ את הדבר שבו הוא תלוי.
אבל בכלל, כדי שנוכל לייצג את התת עץ באיזושהי צורה ולא פשוט לייצג אותו כמילה אחת, אנחנו צריכים שהשכבות קודם לכן איכשהו יעשו לו קואליציה.
כן. אז כאן אולי אפשר לקבל איזושהי אינטואיציה.
שוב, זה נפנופי ידיים כמו כל דבר בדיפ Learning אבל או כמעט כל דבר.
אבל בסופו של דבר זה נותן איזושהי אינטואיציה לגבי איפה המבנה העמוק הזה יכול לעזור.
שוב תרגישו. אני עובר על זה בקצרה כי זה דברים שדיברנו עליהם, אבל תרגישו חופשי לעצור אותי.
זה דברים שיהיו לנו חשובים להמשך. אז נתנו דוגמה מתוך ה Illustrated Transformer, שזה איזשהו בלוג פוסט מאוד נחמד לגבי איך זה עובד.
אמרנו שבגדול מה שיש לנו זה שלוש מטריצות. נכון, מטריצה אחת שהופכת את ה input את האיקסים שנכנסים לסרט attention layer is.
כן, הוקטורים שאנחנו קוראים להם Curves. מטריצה שניה שהופכת את האין פוטים לכח.
כן. שאכזבה צריכים להיות. מה אפשר להגיד על המימדים שלהם?
המימדים של הוקטורים שאנחנו מקבלים. כן שווים.
נכון הם שווים כי צריך לעשות להם מכפלה סקלר נכון? וככה לקבל את ה score.
כן כמה? כמה חזק? כמה כמה מתוך אחד נגיד אחד.
K2 זה כמה מתוך הוקטור value של אינדקס 2.
אנחנו רוצים להכניס לתוך output וקטור של 1.
כן, ודיברנו על הדברים האלה. אמרנו שיש שם גם איזה גורם נרמול, אבל זה פשוט קבוע.
אז הספורים האלה עוברים soft מקס, ומה שאנחנו מקבלים בסוף זאת זה צירוף קמור,
לא בדיוק של האיקסים שנכנסו, אלא של איזושהי מכפלה של האיקסים שנכנסו כפול מטריצה דאבליו V של Values.
שוב אני עובר על הכל מהר, אבל באמת תעצרו אותי אם זה אתם לא זוכרים את זה או שצריכים גם זה חזרה נוספת.
כן. אז כתבתי את זה גם בצורה יותר מסודרת כמו שכתבתי. כתבתי את זה בגדול על הלוח, אז הכנסתי את זה גם למצגת.
אז אלה דברים שפשוט דיברנו עליהם. על המקרה הכללי? כן, שבהם יש לנו n וקטורים שאנחנו רוצים מהם לייצר n וקטורים.
אז כן, מייצרים מטריצה של איריס, מטריצה של Keys,
מטריצה V של values ומייצרים מטריצה שהיא פשוט Soft Max שמתקבל במכפלות של iris הרלבנטיים כפול ה value הרלוונטי.
אוקיי. אוקיי, והזכרנו לקראת הסוף את ה multi hand attention שמה זה אולי מישהי או מישהו זוכרים?
כן כן, נכון. אז אולי יש עוד מישהו כאן שרוצה להשתתף?
כן, לא הרמת יד כמו שחשבנו אותו ביחד, זה נכון.
אז פשוט עשינו את זה כמה פעמים. מה זה אומר? כמה heads?
אבל הרי האינפוט אותו input. אז באיזה מובן זה? למה שייצא לי משהו אחר?
כן כן, בדיוק. אז המטריצות האלה הן פר head. נכון, הם פר head ואז אנחנו מייצרים.
רגע רגע. זה לא משופר. זה לא כאילו I לוקח את העין בלי שהפעלת i מינוס אחד?
לא. Multi head. אתה מדבר על עומק עומק? Multi head attention זה לא עומק.
זה מאוד חשוב להדגיש. כן, multi head הכוונה היא זה עדיין שכבה אחת של multi head attention.
כן. אז כפי שכתוב לכם כאן אתם יש לכם כמה מטריצות.
אוקיי, כמה heads? זה תלוי בארכיטקטורה. זה לא משהו שלומדים אותו בדרך כלל.
כן, זה תלוי בארכיטקטורה. יש לכם כמה heads, כל אחד מהם יש לו מטריצה משלו.
אנחנו מקבלים 100 מטריצות האלה את.
סליחה, הייתי צריך לכתוב פה איקס לא? ודאבל כן.
אוקיי. על כל פנים אנחנו מייצרים כן, כמו שעשינו כאן.
אנחנו מייצרים מטריצות של keys ו values לכל head ובסוף משחררים אותם.
כן, כאן מה שאני רציתי לכתוב זה כן.
מה שרציתי לכתוב זה שזה מכפילים את זה ב input אז אני אשנה סליחה, אבל מה שעושים זה מקבלים בעצם את הערכים.
את הוקטורים האלה שהם עירוב של של הווקטורים שנכנסו, של האינפוט וה Actors.
כל פעם באיזושהי קומבינציה שונה ובסוף משרשרת ומכפילים באיזושהי מטריצה שבדרך כלל מורידה את זה למימד שלא תלוי במספר העץ.
אבל זה עניין של קונבנציה של ארכיטקטורה בנויה. כן, זה גם ילדותי.
איתמר. Tweet. כשאנחנו עושים ספורט, אומר גרינברג, יוצרת.
קשר עם נקודה טובה למה שנרצה לעשות את זה?
למי יש רעיון? גני הילדים של הקומפלקס?
כן. אז אוקיי, אז אתן דוגמא נגיד אולי 2 heads שנראים מתקבלים על הדעת.
הרי מה זה הד הד? זה אומר בגדול שני דברים כן, זה אומר איך זה אומר מטריצה של דאבליו V?
נכון? זאת שכאילו עושה לי הטלה, אבל זה נגיד יחסית בקטנה.
זה סך הכל מטריצה אחת שכוללת את כולם. ואולי משמעותי יותר זה איזה קומבינציה, איזה מקדמים קמורים היא לוקחת, נכון?
איפה העתיד של מושקע עם יותר באינדקס הזה באינדקס הזה?
נכון, כל HDD שונה מזה. אז למה שנרצה כמה סטים שונים של מקדמים קמורים?
סליחה. מסיבות שהן ממש שונות. בואו לראות שאתה לא באמת מצליח לראות את אותן כמות מאמץ.
לפעמים אתה רוצה לשאול שאלות מורכבות, לוגיות, לפעמים רוצים לשאול שאלות בלי לראות, אבל השאלה המתבקשת תהיה אנחנו דיברנו,
בעיקר אם אני זוכר נכון בהקשר של הצגת תגובות, הפגת עניינים הפוכה, כלומר השגת עמימות שמתאפשרת רק אחרי הפגת עמימות פשוטה.
לא שנייה עוד לא דיברנו על עומק. רגע, חכה, עוד לא משנה.
נשאלת אם אתה לא רוצה לעשות את זה גם לעומק וגם לרוחב. כן, בוודאי שכן, אבל פשוט עוד לא דיברנו על זה.
כן. אז בקיצור. כן, בדיוק.
זאת אומרת, יכול להיות שיש הרבה דברים. תשימו לב שכל אוסף של מקדמים קמורים או בעצם הם משחקים משחק סכום אפס ביניהם.
נכון, אם אני לוקח יותר מאחד אני לוקח פחות מאחר.
אין מה לעשות, זה הכל. חייב להסתכם לאחד נכון.
ואז בעצם זה מסתבר כן, שפשוט הלמידה היא יותר פשוטה באמת, בייחוד במקרים שבהם יש כמה מימדים צריך לקחת בחשבון.
אז ניקח נגיד דוגמא. אוקי, נגיד שהיה לנו make more difficult.
אוקיי, כאן זה making. כן, שזו צורה לא מוטה, נכון?
כן sense making. אבל נגיד. נגיד שהיה כתוב פה ו make כן או משהו כזה.
כן די. Or making. או משהו כזה?
כן? אז אם אנחנו מסתכלים על make אז make נכון להסתכל על הבחנה אחרת, נגיד בין מייק למייק.
אוקיי, האם זה משהו? מייק ומקס ובוא נגיד שאנחנו רוצים לעשות משהו שקשור במה שקשור, לא יודע מה אנחנו רוצים לעשות.
יועציה לא נתנו לי שנייה לחשוב. זה המחשבה שלי, לא?
אוקיי, סליחה. בוא נחשוב על שנייה על משהו אחר. בוא נגיד שיש לנו את המקרה באמת של מייק Making more difficult, אבל נגיד השאלה הוא Make it more difficult.
אוקיי, זה גם משהו שהיינו רוצים לייצג איכשהו בתוך זה.
כן, כי למה? כי אולי בעברית שמתרגמת זה כן נצטרך להטות את זה לזכר או נקבה.
אולי סתם אני זורק. כן, יש שפות שאין להן צורה. אינפיניטי בבית מה שנקרא.
כאילו שאי אפשר וצריך להטות את הפעלים. תמיד אי אפשר לשים אותם בצורה לא מוטה.
אז במקרה הזה היה אולי נוח לייצג בטן של Head.
על איזה מילה אני צריך להסתכל כדי לדעת מה המין בעצם בעצם הנושא מילת נושא.
ואתן שנגיד אחר שמסתכל על אלברט Difficult. על more difficult.
כן, כשהוא עושה דיסה אז אז יש לזה. מסתבר.
לפעמים זה הופך את הלמידה ליותר אפקטיבית. בסדר, גם דיברנו על זה מאוד.
בקצרה זה עניין טכני שמי שממש מתעניין.
אני חושב שכן. אמרו לי כאן שלומדים עליו יותר ב introduction to deep learning.
כל העניין הזה של learning connections. אני לא מתעמק בזה כאן.
זה מין חומר כללי של Deep Learning שאיכשהו מייצב את כן את האימון ואת ההיסק, אבל פשוט זה גם קיים.
בגלל זה הזכרתי את זה. ואז הגענו לארכיטקטורת Transformer עצמה.
כן, זה הגענו לקראת סוף השיעור הקודם ובעצם דיברנו על זה שהיה פה מקל.
אה, הנה. כן. אז דיברנו על זה שיש לה בעצם שני חלקים.
נכון, חלק אחד קראנו ה Encounter והשני הדיכאון והרציונל שלה, כמו בדרך כלל במודל In Order Disorder, הוא הרציונל הבא.
הרשת הזאת מגדירה. למרות שהרבה פעמים קוראים לזה מודל סיקוונס סיקוונס.
כן, לפעמים זה מין שם כזה נפוץ. לא יודע אם יצא לכם לשמוע אותו סיקוונס.
כן. היא בעצם לא רשת שחוזה סיקוונס.
נכון, היא לא חוזה סיקוונס דיקציה שלה. היא לא סיקוונס? ממש לא.
היא דבר אחר. מה הוא? מה האאוטפיט של הרשת הזאת?
מה יצא לי פה? מי אמר מילה?
כן, או למעשה קצת יותר מדויק. זה בדיוק וקטור התפלגות על פני מילים נכון וקטור בקיצור הדבר הזה.
זאת רשת שמטרתה לחזות התפלגות על פני המילה הבאה בהינתן המילים הקודמות.
כלומר, משפט שהכנסנו לתוך העין של הדג קוטר שהוא בעצם האלקטורט של כל הרשת.
כן כן, קוטר ה output שלו הולך לדיכאון. כן, כפי שאתם רואים אין לו output כללי.
זה הכל סמנטית. בדיוק כל אוצר המילים של ה output של שפת היעד.
לפעמים יש אוצר מילים אחר ב input ובאוטובוס הזה technical rates.
מאד מאד גדול של פלט של אורז פרסי.
נשמע קצת אה? אז אולי אנחנו עוד מעט נדבר על זה.
זה מה שתשמור את השאלה הזאת לשיעור על פרי טריינינג, שזה בדיוק.
נגיע לזה בהמשך היום. אוקיי, אבל נכון, אם יש לנו אוצר מילים גדול, אז soft Max הזה הוא על פני הרבה דברים.
אבל מה קורה בעצם? אוקיי, אז בסוף יש לנו שכבה לינארית וסופר מקס שמייצרת לנו איזושהי התפלגות.
אבל מה קורה ליעד? אז כן, בעצם מה מוזן לתוך אותה שכבה לינארית בסוף?
מקס זה הארט פוט של Oder, והוא עצמו מתקבל על ידי ה output שלהם Loader שדיברנו עליו בשיעור שעבר.
אני אחזור אליו מאוד מאוד בקצרה. האינפוט.
כן. אז ה input זה מצד אחד ה output של ה Encounter שדיברנו עליו פעם שעברה ומצד שני הפרי פיקס.
כן, כלומר מה שההתחלה, הרישא של התרגום כן, שאותה אנחנו רוצים בעצם את ההמשך שלה אנחנו רוצים לחזות.
אחלה. עכשיו איך זה עובד? בגדול, מה שיש לנו כאן זה הרבה שכבות.
כן, זה הכפול n הזה שאתם רואים כאן. אוקיי, אז זה בדיוק העומק שדיברנו עליו, אבל כל שכבה היא לא סתם self attention, אלא היא Multi head self attention.
אם קלטי הזה של העט של ה learn more והרי dual connections ואחרי זה זה מוזן לפיד Forward Network, שהיא בדרך כלל די קטנה.
ושוב עושים שם את אותו Ritual Connections, ולרוב הדבר הזה מייצר אחרי שעושים את כל התהליך המסובך הזה ועושים אותו אין פעמים.
מה שמתקבל זה בעצם סדרה של וקטורים, נכון?
כמה? אגב? אתה לא מבין?
בקיצר. אתה לא מספר הוקטורים שיוצאים מכאן שווה ל את מספר.
כן, מספר האינפוט מספר טוקנים שנכנסו פה בסדר וזה תמיד fixed.
מה קורה אם יש לנו משפט קצר שאנחנו רוצים לתרגם Padding?
נכון יש Token Padding Token מיוחדים שהם פשוט עוד משהו שתמיד נכנס לתוך אוצר המילים שלי בספר אני לא יכול להפסיק.
לא, זה קבוע. זו הצורה שבה מאמנים טרנספורמציה.
תשמע, אם אתה רוצה לקחת אותי קודם מה שנכנס, מה שיוצא Bianconeri אותו מספר של טוקנים שנכנסו זה אותו מספר של טוקנים שיצאו.
האם אתה שואל אותי תמיד במובן הזה, האם אנשים עושים כל מיני דברים אחרים?
כן. האם אתה שואל אותי תמיד במובן הזה? אבל זאת לא השאלה הרלוונטית.
השאלה הרלוונטית זה האם בארכיטקטורת הווניל, הטרנספורמציה שאותה אנחנו לומדים בקורס הזה?
ככה זה עובד. כן, זה מה שתמצאו במאמר. אתן שניזון ממני וזה מה שאנשים התכוונו אליו שיגידו ואני לטרנספורמציה.
אוקיי, יפה. אז קיבלנו את ה n ווקטורים האלה או כמספר ה Token.
עכשיו הדבר הזה עובר ל. וכדרכם של דברים מה שהוא מקבל זה את הפרי פיקס.
כמובן. אמרנו שאם מוסיפים לו את ה position encoding, שאולי מישהי או מישהו זוכרים מה זה יזכירו לנו?
לאכול או לתפוס את השמות של המשתמשים?
בדיוק בדיוק. אז בעצם? אז בואו נסתכל בעצם כן, אם נעשה אולי איזשהו תרגיל קטן, אתם יודעים מה?
זה יעזור לנו לעבור את כל הנקודה. אז בוא נסתכל על הנקודה.
כן, בוא נסתכל על איזה פרמטרים יש לו.
אז בואו נשים לב. דבר ראשון יש את כל העסק של ה self attention נכון?
איזה פרמטרים יש לו למולטי head? Self attention שזה רק חלק מהם.
W, w, w.
V. כמה כאלה יש בכל שכבה מספר הראשים כמספר הראשים, נכון?
אז יש לנו i. כשאני הולך מפה מסמנים את זה 1 עד H קטן מספר הראשים.
אוקיי. מה עוד יש?
יש כאלה? אם כן אז על ADD פלוס Num אין שם עוד פרמטרים.
נכון יש את הפיד forward כן feed forward. יש לו איזושהי מטריצה שם שאו כמה מטריצות אם זה כמה שכבות כן מה אתה אומר למעלה משנה?
אוקיי. נכון, בדיוק. אז בוא נעשה את זה באמת לפי הסדר. אז יש את דאבליו? או שזה המטריצה שהופכת כמה הדים לאחד?
כמה כאלה יש לנו פר שכבה אחד נכון?
כי יש רק אחד לכל ההדים, אבל כמובן שיש לנו כזה אחד לכל ריבוע כזה ויש לנו n גדול כאלה.
נכון אחד לכל שכבה. אז אני כבר מסמן שכאלה יש לנו אין.
כן, אז עכשיו אין שכבות multi head.
Self attention. בסדר, אחלה.
מה עוד יש לנו? אז באמת הזכרנו את הפיד פורוורד נטוורק?
אז יש את הפרמטרים. של הפיד פורוורד וכאלה.
כמה עותקים יש גם אין נכון, כי אני מדבר עכשיו רק על Include נכון?
כי יש לנו אין בלוקים תכלת כאלה ב Encounter. אין שכבות כן?
אז בעצם היינו פה. צריכים לסמן משהו. כמו כן צריך להוסיף עוד.
כן מה שהוא אומר זה כבר שאלה של איך אתם אוהבים לאנדקס את זה, אבל נגיד לפעמים כותבים את זה Double high.
נגיד זה הולך על השכבות, נגיד.
וגם כאן. אז פרמטרים איך שתרצו לאנדקס את זה כפול n גדול פעמים יפה זה או זה.
זה בעצם הבלוקים האלו. נכון, אבל זה לא הסוף.
זאת אומרת זה כן הסוף, אבל זה לא ההתחלה. חסר לנו את ההתחלה. גם להתחלה יש פרמטרים.
כמה פרמטרים יש שם? אז בוא נראה מה קורה בהתחלה.
יש לנו שני דברים input עם padding ו position all encoding או position עם Beds.
איך הם? כמה פרמטרים יש שם? אז בוא נגיד שהממד.
אוקיי, אז input עם Padding.
כמה יש לנו? כן, אז וקטורים נכון, כל וקטור של input עם Padding הוא בגודל D.
לא משנה המימד הפנימי של הרשת שני מימדי. כמה כאלה יש לקפל בגודל?
לא. אני מדבר עכשיו פרמטרים של הרשת, אבל זה לא מושג מה זה.
זה הרבה פעמים כן רוצים שזה ילמד. אתה צודק שהיה אפשר להגדיר את זה.
כסף מאוזן. כן, כאילו פשוט להגיד הנה קיבלתי אותה מאיפשהו.
לא יודע, סקיפ גרם או מה שזה לא יהיה. הרבה פעמים אתה כן רוצה לאמן אותם, או לפחות אולי לאתחל אותם בצורה אינטליגנטית, אבל אחרי זה כן לתת לו לשבת להתאמן.
כן, זה תלוי כבר במימוש, אבל כן, הרבה פעמים כן נותנים. אז כמה יש שם?
כן, גודל אוצר המילים נכון? אז כאן יש כגודל אוצר המילים שר המילים וקטורים.
כן. אז כן.
אז נגיד סך הכל נגיד D כפול V פרמטרים.
ויש מה עוד? כן. למה זה?
לא עובד? צריך לתת הסכמה כדי לעשות את זה?
לא? הדדי. לכל Token אתה צריך וקטור!
הוא באמת בגודל D. כן כלומר אתה לא נותן.
זה לא one HOT? כן, אם זה היה one hot factors נכון אז בעצם זה היה ממימד עצום ורק וקטור זה היה של וקטור יחידה.
אבל הסאנס בבאגי הגדול הזה יש לנו בגילאי מקיף קונספט.
כן אז יש לך אין מילים כלב, חתול, שולחן, כיסא וכן הלאה.
כל אחד מהם יש לו איזשהו וקטור ממדי שמתאים לו.
אז למה זה בגדולה ולא כלום מבחינת הקלט של הרשת?
אין מילים. באמת לא. אתה צודק שכל הרצה ספציפית של הרשת לא.
כנראה לא תשתמש בכל אוצר המילים, אבל עכשיו אנחנו שואלים כי הפרמטרים של המודל נכון.
פרמטרים של המודל זה השאלה כמה ערכים אתה צריך לשמור נכון כדי שתוכל לחשב.
לעשות פורוורד באס לא יודע לעשות אינפלציה. כן וזה.
אין מה לעשות, אתה חייב להיות מוכן לכל מילה באוצר המילים. אוקיי. ומה לגבי ה position encoding?
אז גם הם? מה זה ה position encoding? כמה אנחנו צריכים?
כמה פסוקים רצופים משתקפות במשפט? בדיוק. אז קוראים לזה לפעמים קונטקסט Lay.
אז אז זה הקונטקסט Lang.
כפול D. אוקיי, אז אם תשימו לב השכבה הראשונה הזאת זה סתם.
אני אומר זה נראה לי אתם. מי שייקח NLP מתקדם. תדברו על זה יותר.
אבל תשימו לב שבהרבה פעמים בהחלט יכול לקרות מצב שהחלק הזה.
כן, הקטנצ'יק הזה פה בעצם יתפוס נתח מאוד משמעותי מכמות הפרמטרים.
כן, בגלל שכפי שאתם רואים, הקונטקסט ובוודאי עוקביו לרי סייז יכולים להיות ממש גדולים.
כן, אז זה בהחלט מקום שלפעמים משתדלים לחסוך בו.
למרות שלכאורה זה רק שכבה אחת ברשת. טוב, זה באמת מקשה אחת, אבל כן, למרות שלפעמים לא משנה בסדר.
שכבה אחת בסדר אז אז זה הניקוד.
ועכשיו בדיוק הגענו לדבר על Order. אז בואו נדבר על זה בגדול.
Order. אם תשימו לב יש לו סך הכל הוא נראה די דומה קצת יותר ארוך כי נוספו לו עוד כמה אלמנטים בסדר בסוף יש איזה Linear soft max.
כלומר בסוף איכשהו צריך להטיל את זה למימד אוצר המילים Fun.
בסדר, זה סך הכל משהו סטנדרטי. אבל איך, איך?
איך נוצר? איך נוצרים כאן הוקטור? אז בעצם מה שקורה כאן זה שההתחלה היא מאוד דומה למה שאנחנו מכירים Encoding.
כן, זה ה output. מוסיפים כל אחד מהם כן output.
כלומר ה x הכוונה. כתוב כאן output עם padding ולא input עם Padding.
בגלל שבמקרים שאנחנו לא עובדים עם אותו אוצר המילים נכון, לפעמים אנחנו נכון.
אתם רוצים לתרגם? לא יודע מה מאנגלית ליפנית?
כן, אולי אתם לא רוצים שאוצר המילים כאילו אוסף ה Carrier שאתם יכולים לייצג באנגלית יכלול גם אותיות ביפנית או מילים ביפנית.
אז אתם רוצים להפריד? הרבה פעמים היום מודלים של אני אומר לפעמים כי הרבה פעמים מודלים של תרגום הם בעצם Multilingual.
יש שם הרבה שפות להרבה שפות ואז הרבה פעמים כן לוקחים אוצר מילים משותף.
אבל בסדר, מותר. אין, אין כאן, אין, אין הכרח לקחת אותו משותף.
אז אנחנו לוקחים את האאוטפיטים. בדיוק כל Token יש לו איזשהו Embed ing position all encoding.
לכל אחד מהם. לכל אחד מהם מוסיפים את ה position encoding ומה שאנחנו רואים זה שזה נכנס פה למשהו שנקרא must Multi head attention שתכף נסביר מה הכוונה בו.
ואז ה output שלו נכנס יחד עם ה Encounter לתוך attention נוסף.
אוקיי, אז יש פה משהו שצריך ביאור. כן, דבר ראשון מה?
מה הוא אותו Messaging שמדובר עליו? כן, מה הוא אותו מיסוך?
והשני הוא מה זה אומר? Multi header tension?
כן כשבעצם הוא לא self. כן הוא כאילו הוא מקבל אוסף של וקטורים.
נכון אתם רואים?
הוא מקבל אוסף של וקטור עם סדרה של וקטורים Order והוא מקבל סדרה של וקטורים מהדי Code נכון של הפרי פיקס בעצם שהוזן לו אז והוא פולט משהו שהוא כמספר,
זאת אומרת כמספר הפתוגנים בדיקור. כלומר, הוא מקבל שתי סדרות ומוציא משהו באורך של אחת מהן.
אוקיי, אז יפה, אז בוא נתחיל מהשני. כן.
קוראים לזה לפעמים. Cross attention כן cross attention. הכוונה היא זה בעצם מקרה שבו אנחנו עושים attention.
Attention שבו. כן iris מגיעים ממקור אחד והכיס מגיעים ממקור אחר.
במקרה שלנו. בעצם מה קורה כאן? אז בואו נחשוב על זה שניה.
אנחנו רוצים לייצר כן, בעצם אנחנו בכל שכבה רוצים לייצר עם Padding חדשים.
Token נכון ל טוקנים של code. אז בעצם מה קורה כאן נכנס.
יש לנו את הכח וכך וקטורים של הדיכאון שנכנסו.
אתה יודע, נקרא להם Y אחד y שתיים.
עד y. אתה יודע, קונטקסט בוא נקרא לזה C זה context length.
כן, ועכשיו אנחנו רוצים. הדבר הזה הולך להיכנס לתוך איזשהו מולטי tension.
שהולך הולכים לצאת לנו פה. סדרה חדשה של Y וקטורים ושל C וקטורים.
אבל כדי לחשב את הוקטורים האלה, אנחנו לא נסתפק רק בייצוג של הפרי פיקס.
זה לא יהיה רעיון טוב, נכון? כי זה פשוט אומר שאנחנו מתעלמים ממה שאנחנו רוצים לתרגם.
כן, כדאי שניקח בחשבון גם את מה אנחנו רוצים לתרגם, אז הוא גם נכנס, ובקטגוריה של ה Transformer הוא נכנס בכל שכבה.
אוקיי, הוא לא נכנס רק ל לא יודע על ההתחלה. ואז משם כבר מפעפע בכל שכבה.
הוא מוזן שזה מה שמגיע מהאין קודם. נכון?
אז האינקובטור עבד קשה. פלט סדרה של זדים.
נגיד שזה אותו קונספט אקסלנס אז זה קריטי, נכון?
ועכשיו הדבר הזה הולך ללכת. וגם להיכנס לפה כן.
אז גם? בסדר, הסיטואציה ברורה.
אז יפה. אז בעצם מה שאנחנו רוצים לעשות, מסתבר לפחות ככה הוגדר ארכיטקטורת ה Transformer.
עדיין רוצים לעשות self עדיין רוצים לעשות extension כמעט בדיוק באותו אופן שדיברנו קודם.
ההבדל היחידי הוא שעכשיו אכזבה. הרי לא מגיעים מאותו סט.
כן, במקרה כאן ספציפית. Keys הם super set כאילו הקבוצה שהם מגיעים מהם הם בעצם סופר סט של הקורס.
בסדר, אבל חוץ מזה זה נראה בגדול אותו דבר. מה שיש לנו בעצם איזושהי מטריצה שהיא מתרגמת את אלה לקיר.
המטריצה הזאת גם מתרגמת את אלה ל Keys.
כן, ויש לנו קווירי קווירי פועל רק על המטריצה הזאת.
נכון, כי אין לנו עוד אינפוט.
אם אנחנו לא מעדכנים את האינפוט של כאילו את האאוטפיטים שלה.
כן, את האינפוט עם Bad things. וחוץ מזה זה חישוב זהה לחלוטין.
בסדר. שאלות לגבי זה בא לי לפני ה value מאיפה הם?
אז בוא נחשוב מה קורה ל values. כן.
אז בעצם זה בדיוק? אם ניזכר, בואו ניזכר לחוות את המנגנון של Retention, ונראה שזה דורש בעצם הבדל מאוד קטן.
בעצם היה לנו איזה שהיא מטריצה שיצרה לנו מתוך התאים האלה.
נכון, יצרה לנו בעצם קיר קווירי, כאילו שלוש מטריצות אחת היא צרכי זה שנייה ושלישית Values.
אז יש לנו בעצם. קיו 1.
אני לא יודע איך נקרא לו קיו. איך נסמן את זה?
שזה יהיה פורט? קיו של וואי.
1. תג? עד של Y?
C. כן זה iris נכון?
והוליווד זה. רק שהכריז עכשיו בעצם אנחנו מייצרים קייס גם מכאן, אבל גם מכאן.
אוקיי, ואז מה שאנחנו צריכים זה בעצם מה שאנחנו מקבלים.
זה k של. Y אחד תג עד k k של y.
C tag. K של זוג.
אחד. של C.
כאילו סט אחד שמתקבל מאלו סט אחד שמתקבל מאלו.
ועכשיו אני יכול לקחת את כל המכפלות, לעשות סוף מקס ולקבל איזשהו צירוף קמור על גבי אלו.
בסדר, ואולי יש לי כמה כאלה כי זה מולטי הד ואז משם הכל עובד.
תודה. אוקיי, אז זה אלמנט אחד.
מה זה אומר המולטי Head Attention שמקבל גם מפה וגם מפה?
קוראים לזה לפעמים cross attention. כן, כאילו כדי להבדיל את זה self attention כאילו אני מסתכל גם הצידה, לא רק למטה.
בסדר, אז זה cross settings זה סתם שם. ומה הכוונה ב mask?
אז זה בעצם בנוי בצורה כזאת או מה שנקרא mask self.
השכבה הראשונה שלו. מה שנקרא Mesh self attention שבגדול mesh self attention.
זה פשוט שם גדול למשהו מאוד פשוט. מה שזה אומר זה שכתיבה וציות שהוא מחשב הוא בעצם עושה להם Caching.
כן הוא לא משנה אותם אחור. אז מה הכוונה? אוקיי, אז מה הכוונה?
אתם עכשיו עושים Self אתם עכשיו עושים נגיד self attention רגיל.
אוקיי. נגיד הייתם עושים self רגיל.
עכשיו הם מכניסים לכם את הפרי פיקס של התרגום בסדר ההתחלה של התרגום כך וכך מילים הראשונות שלו, ואתם עכשיו רוצים לחזות את.
את המילה הבאה. אז באופן עקרוני כל מילה. נכון שאני מחשב לה את.
האאוטפיטים כאילו הייתה עם Padding שיוצא מהסל. Attention.
יכול להיות תלוי בכל אחד מהאחרים. נכון בהתאם אין שום מגבלה לאינדקס 5.
להיות תלוי באינדקס 17 ועל ההפך ולא משנה מה נכון אין שום.
שום אילוץ לא משנה כפי שאפילו אמרתי לכם בשיעור שעבר. פעם עשינו במעבדה ניסוי שבו עשינו מוטציה של כל.
המשפט, והוא למד את זה כאילו כל המשפטים אותה מוטציה. זה בכלל לא עניין את ה Transformer הגיע בדיוק לאותם ביצועים.
חוץ מזה שעכשיו הפלט שלו היה משפטים באיזה סדר ביזארי, אבל בדיוק אותו סדר שבו יצרנו את האימפקט.
אז בסדר, אז self attention אין לו כיווניות. Mask self attention בעצם אומר כשאני מחשב את מספר 5.
אוקיי, נגיד אני עכשיו מחשב את הפרי פיקס באורך 5.
בסדר, כי כי בעצם הקונטקסט שלי הוא אולי 8.
בסדר. כל הגודל כאילו של של של האינפוט לדייק הוא בגודל 8.
אבל עכשיו אני חווה את איזה מילה את ההתפלגות על המילה השישית, נכון?
אז אני צריך להזין את חמשת הראשונות ולהזין פה? מה זה כן איזה Padding כזה?
אבל בעצם הוא לא הולך להתעלם ממנו. תכף תראו. בסדר. אז בעצם נכון, אוקיי, אז זה הולך להתעלם.
ועכשיו מה שאני עושה זה בעצם אני מחשב את כן, אני מחשב פה איזשהו attention,
ואם הייתי עושה self attention באופן עקרוני הייתי יכול להסתכל על כל אחד מהמילים.
עכשיו אתה אומר טוב, פה אין שום דבר נורא מעניין להסתכל על זה סתם, אפילו אם הייתי מסתכל זה היה פד.
אז מה כל כך חשוב לי לא להסתכל עליהם? ממילא זה משהו שהוא חסר חשיבות, אבל זה לא מדויק.
כן, כי עכשיו תחשבו על זה שבעצם כן.
אם הייתם מרשים, אם לא הייתם עושים מסקינג, כלומר לא הייתם עושים Caching של האקטיביות הקודמות אז בעצם הכתיבה חציה שלו?
כן. כלומר האם Padding שלו כשהוא יוצא כאן היה לא היה אותו דבר כמו Output שלו כשהייתי כן?
כאילו בסיבוב הבא אני אחזור על זה עוד פעם.
נגיד עכשיו אנחנו אנחנו חוזים את המילה החמישית. אוקיי, אז זזנו רק את ארבע הראשונות בפרויקט.
בסדר. ועכשיו חישבתי את האקטיביות. הם עשו פה איזה מיקס, קיבלתי לכל אחד מהם וקיבלתי לכל אחד מהם attention שתלוי בכל אחד מהארבעה.
כן הוא השילוב של כל הארבעה האלה בסדר. עכשיו הגעתי ועזבתי את חמש לדיכאון, כי עכשיו אני רוצה לחזות את המילה השישית חזית עם משהו בחמש.
לא משנה מה. עכשיו אני מזין אותו לדיכאון ואני רוצה לחזות את המילה השישית.
האם Padding של 4 יכול עכשיו להסתמך על ה Investing הזה?
נכון? לכן הוא לא יהיה אותו דבר כמו האם Padding.
לא יהיה יכול להסתכל על זה במילים אחרות. ולמה זה משנה?
הרי אתם אומרים אבל מה זה משנה לי? ממילא אני עושה de coding רק מהאיבר האחרון של המילה הבאה.
אז מה אכפת לי? 4. עם מי יכולה להסתמך על 5 או לא להסתמך על 5?
מתי זה? איך זה ישפיע על 5? 2.
שלום רב! איך האם Padding של 4?
טון זה בסדר? כן, אבל מה שאני מתכוון לומר זה בעצם לכאורה.
אם הייתי עושה פה self attention רגיל, אז האם Padding של 4 היה גם מבוסס על 5?
נכון, ואז כשהוא יוצא החוצה בעצם ותזכרו שהדבר הזה הוא SPECT עליו יש עוד self attention ועוד ועוד.
אז בעצם במילים. במילים אחרות. הכתיב זה ששיניתי את האם Padding של 4 של מספר 4 בשכבה הראשונה, כי עכשיו הוא גם יכול להסתמך על המילה שנמצאת ב 5.
אוקיי, ישפיע על דיקציה של 5 בשכבה הבאה כי ה 5 בשכבה הבאה הסתכל על 4 שתלוי גם בזה.
נראה לי שעדיין לא שכנעתי אתכם לצייר את זה על הלוח. אולי. אולי זה יותר ברור.
אוקיי, זו נקודה קצת מבלבלת. למעשה, כל כך מבלבלת שסטודנט שלי עבד על.
הוא עבד על ארכיטקטורה. דוקטורנט שלי לשעבר לשם חושן.
אז הוא עבד. הוא עשה עבודת דוקטורט, בין השאר על הארכיטקטורה של ה Transformer.
הוא רצה להוציא ארכיטקטורה קצת שונה. איזשהו וריאנט שאלה שיש לו איזשהם יתרונות מסוימים.
והנקודה הזאת? בהתחלה זה לא כתוב בכלל במאמר.
ייתכן שמזוהה יונית. כאילו זה כתוב באיזשהו רמז.
וכאילו ומשהו שם לא הסתדר לו ואז כאילו הוא מסתכל והוא בהתחלה לא מבין ואז כאילו הוא נכנס עמוק לתוך הקוד ואמר אה אה, אז זה מה שהם עושים שם.
ואז הוא התחיל לשאול אנשים, כולל אנשים שמתעסקים כל היום וכל הלילה בטרנספורמציה.
והוא שאל אותם תגידו, אתם ידעתם שזה ככה והרבה לא ידעו? כן, היו כאלה שידעו.
כן, מי שממש נמצא ככה בקיץ, אבל הרבה לא ידעו כי זה זה.
אבל נראה לי שמאז כבר יותר אנשים יודעים כי כבר כל העולם מתעסק טרנספורטר ובגלל זה חשוב לי ללמד את זה גם פה.
אז בעצם מה קורה? יש לכם שתי אפשרויות.
בסדר, יש לכם סדרה של וקטורים? אוקיי, נכנסת לכם סדרה של וקטורים.
נגיד ואנחנו כן. אתם רוצים לחזות את המילה הרביעית?
בסדר, אז אתם תעשו פה כל מיני שכבות ובסוף יצא לכם.
נכון, בסוף יצא לכם. ארבעה וקטורים.
תקחו את האחרון, תעשו לה linear ו soft max ותקבלו התפלגות על המילה הבאה נכון?
אז תקחו את זה ותעשו איתו משהו על זה. כרגע זה בעצם האאוטפיטים היחידי שאכפת לכם ממנו.
אוקיי. שתי אפשרויות. רק אחת מהן קורית בפועל.
אפשרות אחת זה להגיד אין Messaging זה פשוט self attention.
בסדר, אז אתם אומרים אוקיי, פטנט שאנחנו מכירים. איך זה עובד?
עושים פה Padding נכון, לאורך השלם של הפרי Fix ואז מחשבים לכל אחד את Padding שלו, שהוא קומבינציה של האחרים באיזשהו חישוב נכון.
אז פה יוצא משהו פה יוצא משהו פה יוצא משהו פה יוצא משהו?
וכן הלאה. זה אפשרות אחת. זה לא מה שקורה.
אוקיי, מה זה mask self attention? זה בעצם משהו מאוד דומה לזה, אבל לא בדיוק.
זה מה שזה עושה. זה עושה את הדבר הבא כשהוא מחשב את צד אחד.
כן, כאילו בסיבוב הראשון ועכשיו נחזור. נגיד אתם עכשיו טריפלקס באורך בעצם בעצם טריפלקס באורך אפס, כאילו פרי פיקס באורך אפס.
כלומר הכל הוא Padding. בסדר, זה קצת מקרה. עזבו, זה כאילו קצת מקרה קצה, אבל הוא גם עובד באותה צורה.
אבל בואו ניקח את אחד אוקיי אחד, זה יהיה יותר ברור. אז נגיד עכשיו אנחנו מסתכלים טריפלקס באורך אחד.
חזינו את המילה הראשונה אנחנו. אנחנו יודעים מה המילה הראשונה. אנחנו רוצים לחזות את המילה השנייה.
בסדר, אלה לא קיימים. אז במקרה הזה אין לו יותר מדי סלף.
אין לו יותר מדי מה לעשות, זה בסדר, הוא עושה self attention והוא ייתן לעצמו אחד פשוט ויחשב איזושהי טרנספורמציה לינארית ואז נון לינארית ו
whatever מה שהוא יעשה שם בסדר ואז feed forward וייצא לו משהו זה נחמד ואז הוא יעשה את זה עוד פעם וייצא לו.
זה צד אחד תג וכן הלאה וכן הלאה עד שיצא לו פה בסוף זה. אף אחד לא יודע מה אין אחרי, אין שכבות ואז נעשה לזה Linear soft.
מקס מקבל משהו? אוקיי, עכשיו מגיע תור שתיים תור שתיים.
חזינו שבעצם מה חזינו? מה המילה השנייה בפרי FX ואנחנו עכשיו רוצים לחזות התפלגות המילה השלישית.
מה נעשה עכשיו? אנחנו יכולים. עכשיו אנחנו נחשב פה איזה חישוב שנעשה.
מה שחשוב הוא שכל הטור הראשון הולך להישאר אותו דבר.
אני הולך להקפיא אותו שלא כמו ב self attention, נכון self attention.
כשאני מחשב את אחד לא אכפת לי שקודם חישבתי משהו.
עכשיו יש לי את 1 ויש לי את 2 ואני אייצר את אחד קומבינציה של אחת ושתיים.
אבל עכשיו לא אחד נסמך על אחד בסדר.
אז עכשיו זד אחד יישאר מה שהוא היה קודם וזה 2 הוא כן כמובן יכול גם להסתכל לכאן וגם לכאן.
ואז? כן. וזה ממשיך באותה צורה.
כן, גם השכבה הבאה יכולה להסתכל על זה. אחד הקודם שהיה כי נשאר אותו דבר.
לא השתנה שום דבר וזה מהחדש כי קודם לא היה זה.
2 כשיגיע זה. 3 אז זה 2 שחשבתי פה שמסתמך על רק על אחד ושתיים רק על האינפוט של אחת ושתיים יישאר קפוא שלא כמו ב self attention נכון ב self attention.
כשאני מאזין שלושה וקטורים, כל אחד יכול לעשות איזה קומבינציה שהוא רוצה של השלושה שהאזינו לו כאן.
לא אחד מסתכל על אחד שתיים, מסתכל על אחד ושתיים שלוש, מסתכל על אחת שתיים, שלוש וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, אז זה מה שהציור הנחמד פה אמור להביע. אז תשימו לב שזה דקות קטנה אבל חשובה.
למה היא חשובה? לא? למה היא חשובה ואני הנתבע סימן שאיזשהו תימני מגביל באיזשהו הסבר את המאסטר שאומר סתימת פיות ושיש בו בכל זאת איזשהו עניין אופוזיציוני.
אבל זה חלש ואתה בכל זאת צריך לשלם. כן, נכון, לא אתה צריך.
נכון, כי זאת לא המטרה העיקרית שלו לדעתי. זאת לדעתי המטרה העיקרית שלו.
יש מי שעוד יכול לחשוב על סיבה למה זה אולי רעיון טוב? לא, לא מבחינת אקספרסיביות.
ברור למה שלא תסתמך על הפתאים כאילו זה לדמות את זה לדמות את המצב של הפלטפורמה באינטרנט.
אוקיי, אבל עכשיו משהו נורא פרקטי בא לשחק באש והמנגה בעצם תמשיך.
אה כן, נכון, כאילו גם עניין המקביל להיות נכון שבעצם אני, אבל כן, לא בדיוק זה Caching בעצם זה מנגנון Caching, נכון?
אני אומר במקום לחשב. תראו אם הייתם עושים self attention על הדיכאון אתם מייצרים טקסט ארוך.
תרגום אם 500 Token 10000 Token לא משנה לפעם היום מייצרים גם הרבה יותר מזה בסדר.
20 אלף טוקנים במקום לחשב את כל האימות של כל אחד נגיד אחד.
לכאורה הייתם צריכים לחשב אלף פעמים פעם אחת רק בהסתמך על עצמו, פעם בהסתמך על עצמו ועל מספר שתיים על עצמו, המספר של המספר 3 וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
נכון, עכשיו אתם מחשבים אותו פעם אחת שתיים הייתם צריכים לחשב 999 פעמים.
עכשיו אני צריך לחשב אותו פעם אחת וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, אז אתם פשוט עושים Caching. ובגלל שהרשתות הן גדולות ועמוקות חוסך לכם די הרבה.
אוקיי, אז. ואז. אוקיי, אחלה.
אבל גם יש שיקולים אחרים באמת לנושא הזה. וכן, אני רואה שלגמרי גלשתי.
אז על כל פנים זה אבל זה טוב. כאילו שסיימנו את הנקודה הזאת.
אז זה קודר. זה כתוב לכם בגדול כאן ובשיעור ואחרי ההפסקה נדבר קצת על היתרונות שלו.
ונעבור לאבולוציה. אז נצא לרבע שעה הפסקה ונחזור.
אגב, השעון הזה נראה לי לא כל כך מדויק, נכון?
הוא בערך דקה דקה, ממהר. לא דיברנו דקה פחות מדקה, אבל כן, עכשיו 54 וזה גם מקודם החוצה.
כן, זה בסדר. אה, זה סביר? דקה יש גישה למערכת העצבים.
שלכם? נקודת האור.
אז מה בעצם אני רוצה להגיד? תרגום מאנגלית לעברית.
Outlook מכניס את המילים בעברית האם היא אמרה שהיא כבר בחוץ?
הרי שזה נשמע תמחור נכון ואפילו לעניין את המשקיע בערוץ.
אני אומר זאת באנגלית, זה כאילו באנגלית ואז נוצר קשר בין השפות.
כן כן, באיזה סוג של אילן. כל זה כאילו קשה לענות על השאלה כאילו זה קשור פרקטית.
בין אם. אתה רוצה לייצר הסברים איך ואיפה אין צורך.
כאילו כן, יכול להיות שעכשיו נוצר אתה תראה לכאורה. אתה אומר שבוא נגיד שהיא פועלת לקבל משפט יותר מסודר.
אוקיי, כאילו אני לא אומר שזה רעיון טוב. כנראה רוב העולם עובד ככה מאיזושהי סיבה ולא רק כי זה חוסך מלא ולא פוגע בפרטיות.
אבל. לכאורה אתה יכול לדמיין מצב שבו אתה מתרגל משהו זה?
בעצם, רק אחרי שבקבוצת לתרגל כבר אתה הבנת שלא דרשת נכון?
כאילו לתרגם את זה לפרוטוקול.
כיום אני צילמתי עבור כל הקשרים החברתיים בקונסוליה.
כן, אתה צודק. אם אין קול מושלם באמת אז באמת אין צורך.
אבל אם הוא לא שם ובעצם אתה נמצא במצב שבו.
אתה נמצא במצב שבו יש מילה מסוימת שהסרת יש לה, נגיד כמה קילו, אולי אפילו הצהרת מילה של סגירה, אבל לא הצגת אותו נכון.
כלומר, התחלת את המשפט באיזשהו אופן כי חשבת להמשיך אותו בדרך מסוימת.
עכשיו לא עשית טעות במובן הזה שאפשר להמשיך את התרבות שלך גם בתרגום בספריה שלך, אבל לא בדרך שחשבת עליה מראש והבנת את זה רק באמצע.
אתה צודק שייתן קובץ מסוים בגוגל שלך. זה לא אמור לקרות כי כבר שבועות שאני כותב לך את כל מה שהיית צריך.
כל מה שנותר זה לזרוק את החתיכות במקומות בעלי חוש טכני.
זה מה שאני עושה. לא היה איזשהו צורך בכך לפני כמה שנים.
תמיד זה מאוד יפה. ככה זה נבנה.
זה סיפור. כן, בגלל שזה אומר שאתה שומע את הטקסט כאילו כדי לייצר.
אייפד צריך להיות בתג הרשמי. מחשב חזק מאוד פעם.
בדרך כלל זה כאילו לא, אבל בכל פעם אתה לא עושה פעם אחת.
זה מה שחשוב. התחילו להגיד אם יש לך מושג בין אלף התיקים שאמורים להיות מתורגם במשפט הזה.
לא סתם מה שאני מנסה לומר פעם אחת לרצות את העובדות ידועות מראש.
אז אתה לא יודע איך זה עובד.
כן, אבל בואו נסתכל על כל המילים בעצם.
כן, זה כאילו ארכיטקטורה דומה, אבל אז תגלו שכל. קודם כל התחשבות בכל השוק זה בכלל לא הולך לקרות.
עכשיו אתה לא יודע אם אנחנו רוצים לדבר על מכוניות. אולי אני פשוט שמח להסתמך על מה שלפניי, אבל לא יודעות.
הנה אותו רק בעוד 500 צעדים. אני ממש לא יודע מה זה פשוט אם לא היית עושה קשיים זה היה הכבד עוסקים בכל כל סדר היום בין שתי השכבות של מפת התיירות,
אבל צריך להיות בכל מדרג את זה שאתה עושה מעסקי יחסי ציבור.
מאיפה הוא מוכר כל כך? מוזר.
כל מילה בסלע! נכון? כן, אבל זה בסדר.
זו פעם ראשונה שאפשר לאבחן את עצמך.
מה היית עושה אם אפשר להרגיש רע?
אלא אם כן אתה צודק, אז בשביל זה בסדר, אתה צריך להיות ברור.
יתר על כן אתה יודע שאתה רוצה לרשת. היית רוצה לחדש עוד כמה שיותר מידע שאתה לא סתם שובר את הראש עוד יותר.
כל הכבוד! זה סליחה, אבל לא בהכרח. כן, זה מה שאתם חושבים.
לכן צילמתי התבססתי על הטכניקה. הזו בבוץ וריאנטים שלהם על האינקובטור נורא קטן, נורא גדול ומרווח.
מה את עושה? זה נכון? אז למה אתה לא עושה את מה שאני עושה?
טפסים על מנת להגדיר אותו מודל?
אבל בעצם זה לא. אבל יש מצב. זאת אומרת, זה נשמע לי ארבעה חודשים עמוסים מאוד שלא מספיק.
זמן ללמוד. כאילו פתאום נפל דבר.
השייקים, המסעדות הכשרות שאתה יכול. לתפוס בסוף כי אתה יש לך סעיף?
לא, אתה אומר לו לא אינפוט הוא אינה משאבת חלב.
למען הסר ספק שכן, אחרת אני לא זוכר איך זה כן.
בדרך כלל הוא יודע כמה דברים בעצמו לעשות עם זה, אבל כן, גם אם תגיד לי, אין להניח שזה ככה.
מסתבר שכן. יש פלסטיני במשלחת. מה אני יכול להגיד לך?
זה? כלומר, אם היה לך לדעת מספרית אז אולי זה יעזור לך לסכם.
את זה. למשל, כושר גופני גבוה יותר לא מצטלם טוב.
לא רק אולי זה יכול להיות להפסיק לפני. סליחה, אתה יודע, אתה לא ממש מבין.
אתה רואה שמדובר משפחתית ספרדית, אבל. אה, אבל אין הרבה מה להגיד, אבל זה לא מעביר את זה בדרך כלל.
אבל ברור שזה לא נכון. והוא כזה ספרדי, כאילו בדיוק אתה צריך לעשות איזה שינוי קטן וזה כבר תקופה של ממש.
כן, זה משפט אשר אין לי מושג שיש מושג, אבל כמובן שאם מסתכלים.
על זה כל כך קשה לפספס כי מסתכלים עליך.
אתה יכול לעשות. הרבה הרבה בישראל, אבל גם קצת.
יש גם זה דבר פשוט, אבל. זה תפקידו של הספר לעשות עם זה שמה שכתוב פה על הדף כיום אני ממש לא בסדר.
גודל מסוים אני כותב בהערות במצגת. של.
צפון אמריקה. ככה זה שאנשים.
לא נכנסים בו. הרי כל דבר צריך להיות מסודר.
האופציה הראשונה צריכה ללכת סריקה קלה של.
המנוע אצל הבן שלי. לא משנה כמה פעמים.
לעשות סדר בנושא זה צריך לחשוב על סמך מה אתה באמת מבין.
בסופו של. התהליך.
בסופו של דבר. גם בתמונות כל הזמן המושלם.
צריך בסופו. של דבר.
למשל. בית הספר צריך לשנות את עצמו, אמר רבי נחמן מברסלב.
לא, זה לא הכוונה שלי, לא. זה לא. סתם.
שואב? אבל זה לא דבר.
רגיל. עכשיו אנחנו עושים את זה.
חשוב לשמור על. עצמנו.
בוקר טוב, אנחנו משפחה.
פעם ראשונה. שאני.
עושה שימוש בסטרואידים. איך בדיוק?
איך מתמודדים עם הכי טוב מולטיטאסקינג של עשור.
אבל למה לעשות את הדברים האלה שעשו באיזה אתר?
כאילו אתה זוכר שהיה בסיסי כמו סוג של דרך?
אני עכשיו רוצה לעשות דברים. בסדר, היה משהו שאתה מצפה לא להיכנס, שיש עכשיו דברים חדשים.
ואכן סירב בטענה שתסביר. את זה כאילו אין דבר כזה.
אני אפס ממש. אבל ממש.
זה עושה לך את זה? כל כך הרבה מושגים וכל כך הרבה יותר פשוט להזדהות עם הרבה אנשים מבוגרים.
לכן אני רוצה אחד השחקן לא יסבול.
בסביבת יתר. על המידה סגנון לבוש שיש ברשותו.
יש. מספר אינסופי של.
עסקים אשר מגיעים באופן. עצמאי.
ברוכים הבאים עולה השאלה איך לעשות כסף ציבורי של שיפוץ בית?
לחץ כאן. חיסכון פנסיוני שלא מפסידים את ההכנסה שצברתי במשך.
במחקר. הבסיסי.
של. פריס הגעתי למסקנה כי.
יש שני סוגים של רוח. אני עצמי לא קיבלתי ציון לא משהו ואני לא כאילו עזבתי את זה.
אני חושב שאני יכול לקחת את הספר למדעי המחשב.
אני לא מסוגל, כמו גם סריקה של הצוואר. הוא עשה את זה בבקשה.
אתה צריך. להיות מוכן לשלם מס הכנסה נמוכה יחסית, אבל לא יותר מכך.
חיפוש. קצר בגוגל וברשתות חברתיות.
וואללה אישי. מרכז מסחרי גדול.
זה לא חוזר לארץ. זה כזה כבר מוניטין צילום מרהיב.
אנלוגי בלי סוף. זכויות יוצרים?
כמו. כן, אף אחד לא.
נכון, זה לא מספיק. מס הכנסה צריך לבקש.
אף אחד לא מכיר אותי, לא אסטרטגיה עסקית.
אני מקווה שהפעם בשבוע הבא יש את התרומה העיקרית.
של. המוצר הסופי.
פשוט כי זה מה שעושה בית הספר לחיים ומספק.
לא בהכרח משתמשת בהם בצורה יסודית בידיעה שאני יודע שאת לא יודעת.
אני רוצה לשאול אותך משהו קצת לא הבנתי את השאלה הבאה.
בסופו של דבר שחשוב מאוד להקנות השלמות.
הוא לא עשה כלום. אני לא מצליחה לעשות. ספורט טוב.
אוקיי, אז? כן.
היו בהפסקה ששאלו אותי.
בעצם גם שאלו אותי לגבי מה הפרקטיקה הנהוגה היום בקשר תרגום אוטומטי עם Transformers.
בגדול, מה שהכי נפוץ היום זה באמת מודלים שהם מולטי גואלים,
כלומר מודלים שמאמנים אותם על הרבה זוגות שפות, אותו מודל על הרבה זוגות שפות שונים ואז בעצם האינפוט זהה.
הנה משפט. הנה שפת יעד לתרגם אותה לשפה הזאת, וכל מודל תומך בכמה שפות יעד.
הסיבה לזה זה שהרבה פעמים אם שפות הם מספיק דומות,
אז מסתבר ש דאטה או Training data שרלבנטי שפה אחת עשוי להיות רלוונטי גם לאחר נגיד לא יודע ספרדית ופורטוגזית ואיטלקית.
וכן במידה אולי פחותה מזה אנגלית וגרמנית וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, אז לגבי היתרונות של ה Transformers אז בגדול Transformers.
בהתחלה אני חושב שהתוצאות שהם הציגו היו די דומות למה שהציגו קודם הרעננים בתרגום אוטומטי, אבל די מהר הטרנספורטר עקפו אותם, וכיום זאת הטכנולוגיה הבסיסית.
כאמור לכל דבר. עשו לכל מיני דברים פה מודיפיקציה מסוגים שונים, אבל הארכיטקטורה הבסיסית היא בהחלט דומיננטית, גם לא רק ב NLP, אלא גם בהרבה תחומים אחרים.
ומלבד הביצועים, חלק חשוב פה בסיבה ש הטרנספורטר תפסו כל כך טוב.
זה שהרבה יותר קל לאמן אותם מאשר לאמן RNA.
אם כן, אז אם תזכרו גרף החישוב בר עננים הוא בעצם תלוי באורך.
כן, בעצם תלוי באורך האינפוט. כן, תלוי אם זה באורך באורך הקלט באורך שפת המשפט,
בשפת המקור ואם זה RNA Indicator אז בעצם במילה שעכשיו אנחנו עושים לה ועוד של הטרנספורטר יש פשוט אורך קבוע.
הדבר הזה גם בעצם מאוד מקל על אימון במקביל.
כן, כי אם נחשוב על זה שנייה, אם נגיד יש לי עכשיו איזשהו טקסט ארוך.
אוקיי, Parallel טקסט, כלומר דוגמה ודוגמת ותרגום רפרנס.
כן, תרגום אנושי שאני רוצה להתאמן עליו.
אז בעצם אולי מישהי או מישהו יכולים להזכיר מה זה Teacher for Being או איך אנחנו יוצרים training Examples מתוך הזוג הזה?
אם אני לא טועה בג'ינס המפורסם, כל פעם אנחנו מורידים מילה מסוימת ואנחנו נותנים למודל של הקבוצה למצוא אותו כקרוב.
אנחנו מורידים בעצם את כל הסיפא של של התרגום.
כן, לא מילה מסוימת אלא ממש חותכים באיזושהי נקודה.
נכון ואומרים בוא תיתן לי הסתברות כמה שיותר גבוהה למילה הבאה שמופיעה באמת בתרגום רפרנס.
עכשיו בארנבוים נכון. כדי לחשב את ה אקטיבציה של ה כן, כאילו כדי לעשות forward pass.
בעצם כן ולקבל את ה. ולקבל בעצם את.
שנייה אחת בעצם ב Rn.
כדי שאני אוכל לעשות forward pass שעליו אני אעשה back population.
שוב אני תלוי בעומק A.
אני תלוי באיזה מקום אני נמצא עכשיו ולכן בדרך כלל למקבל את זה היה יותר בעייתי, כי בעצם הייתי רוצה להסתמך בחישובים שכבר חישבתי במקום אחד כדי.
בעצם ברשתות יותר קצרות כדי. כדי להיעזר גם כאן וב Transformer.
בגלל הארכיטקטורה היא בעצם ארכיטקטורה קבועה עם עומק קבוע.
בגדול, הצליחו לעשות את הדברים בצורה הרבה יותר יעילה.
מבחינת מקביליות אני מתכוון הרבה יותר פרל לייזר. חוץ מזה, מסתבר גם שאלה Transformer אם יש פחות רגישות ל position.
כן. אז אם אתם זוכרים שדיברנו בסוף הדיון שלנו על עננים, דיברנו על כך שבעצם למרחק יש חשיבות.
כן, אם נגיד אני מסתכל עכשיו על סנדוויץ מודל נכון, ואמרנו אם יש לי שתי מילים שהן תלויות אחת בשנייה, נגיד הטיה, כן, אם זה הטייה לרבים או ליחיד.
בדוגמה שנתנו, ככל שהן יותר רחוקות אני רואה איזושהי סדציה, בייחוד אם יש לי באמצע Structures כאלה.
כן? בגדול, בטרנספורמציה רואים הרבה פחות דיגיטציה כפונקציה של המרחק בגלל ש הארכיטקטורה שלו היא הרבה יותר סימטרית בעצם מבחינת מה יכול לקחת, מה בחשבון.
למעשה היא לגמרי סימטרית.
האסימטריה היחידה נובעת פשוט מעט סימטריות שיש בדאטה שבדרך כלל מילים נוטות להיות יותר תלויות במילים שקרובות אליהן מאשר שמיים רחוקות.
ואז זה Bias שהמודל כאילו פיקסל, אבל אין בארכיטקטורה שום דבר שגורם להטייה כזאת.
אוקיי, וזה מביא אותנו לנושא של של אבולוציה.
האבולוציה שעדיין נחשבת ולידציה הכי לא נאמר הכי איכותית.
אני אוהב לצטט מאמר בדיוק שמסביר מי שמתעניין איך בדיוק עושים את זה, אבל זאת שנחשבת הכי איכותית זה מה שזה.
פשוט human active evaluation. כלומר הנה סקאלה 0 עד 100.
שואל כל מיני אנשים תגידו לי כמה אתם חושבים שזה איכשהו מנרמל את התוצאות, משקלל אותם באיזושהי דרך.
זאת האבולוציה. כן, איכות התרגום שעדיין נחשבת כ gold standard.
אבל בוא נאמר הכי קרוב לזה שיש. אבל כמובן השיטה הזאת היא מאוד יקרה, מאוד יקרה, דורשת הרבה מאמץ אנושי ותקציב,
ולכן בעצם התפתחה מוטיבציה מאוד רצינית לייצר טכניקות אוטומטיות שעושות אבולוציה, וזאת שכנראה אפילו עד ימינו אנו ב 2026.
אני חושב סביב תרגום היא בטח אחת הפופולריות, אם לא הפופולרית ביותר.
באופן קצת מפתיע, כפי שתזכרו זה מדד. Blue score.
כן, לא. לא יודע אם חותם על הפופולרית ביותר, אבל בהחלט מאוד פופולרית ונוכחת, וגם הרבה מדדים אחרים שבאו מאז בעצם מסתמכים עליה.
אז בגלל זה חשוב לי להסביר מה היא אומרת. אז בלוז score כן או ככה אומרים זה באנגלית.
דוברי הצרפתית כאן ודאי יתקנו אותי. כן score או משהו כזה.
כן, נכון, זה בערך ההגייה. אוקיי בלאק.
כן. אמממ. אחלה.
מה זה עושה? אז מהו אותו black score? מה שהוא עושה זה בעצם הוא מחשב.
אין גם אובר לאפ בין בין References, בין כמה References, בין כמה תרגומים ידניים שמשמשים כמעט כמו שמשמשים כרפרנס לבין Output של מודל התרגום.
אבל זה דורש איזשהו תיקון מסוים מסיבות שאנחנו תכף נראה.
אז בואו נבין מה הרעיון. אז הרעיון הוא שאני רוצה לחשב n גם אוברלנד.
בואו נגיד שיש לי שני Candidate ים שאני מנסה לדרג לתת להם.
כן, אלה שני אאוטפיטים של מכונה. Mary No Sleep the Witch Green ו Marie Did not go Back to a Green witch.
אוקיי, נגיד שאלו שתי Candidate אפשריים שאני מקבל ממכונות תרגום, ויש לי References דברים אנושיים שאנשים כתבו.
1. Mary did not the green witch. שניים. Did not the green with Mary did not make the green witch ומרי did not what a green source.
אוקיי, אז בדרך כלל יש כמובן וריאציה.
בדרך כלל הרבה יותר גדולה. זה פשוט משפט מאוד פשוט, אבל יש הרבה מאוד References אפשריים.
אבל בוא נגיד שאספתי כמה. אז מה אני מחשב? אז אני מחשב.
אין גם Precision עבור n עם שונים. אז יוני גרם Precision זה הראשון.
מה הכוונה יוני גרם Precision? כמה מהמילים שמופיעות ב Candidate מופיעות גם Preferences.
אוקיי, אז כמה מילים כאן? מסתבר ש 5 מתוך 6 עבור הראשון איזו מילה לא מופיעה באף אחד.
מה References No בדיוק?
אבל שאר המילים כן. יש לי חמש מתוך שש. עכשיו אני מחשב את אותו דבר לוואי גרם.
אוקיי, כל סוג של מילים. אז יש לי 5 גרמים Candidate one נכון?
Movie now. Now that which witch green.
כל אחד מהם אני יכול לבדוק האם מופיע באחד References ואני מגלה שרק 1.
מי הוא בדיוק? רק סלף והשאר לא?
אז קיבלתי אחד מתוך 15 20 אחוז. אני ממשיך הלאה.
Candidate 2 כנל. מחשב יוני גרם 7 מ 10 גרם, 4 מ 9.
ולמעשה בדרך כלל עושים את זה גם יותר גדולים.
זה כבר תלוי ספציפית בקונפיגורציה. לבלו יש כל מיני קונפיגורציות.
יש n גדול איזשהו היפר פרמטר. כן, בדרך כלל 4 זה המספר הכי מקובל.
כן עד 4 Grams. אז משהו שאפשר לשנות לפי הצורך.
ומה שאני עושה זה בעצם מחשב את ה Precision עבור. יוני גרם בי גרם TRI גרם עד n גדול גרם ומחשב את ה Precision.
מה זה ה Precision מספר? המכנה הוא מספר n גרמים בקנדידה, והמונה הוא מספר ה n גרמים שמופיעים בלפחות אחד References.
כוכבית. למה אני צריך כוכבית? כן.
אז בוא אני אשאל אתכם שאלה. אוקיי, מה אני אשאל אתכם?
שאלה. נגיד. היה לי עכשיו פה קנדידה מספר אחד או קנדידה מספר שלוש היה למשל זה וזה.
אוקיי, זה הרבה יותר פשוט. אוקיי, אז כמה מתוך דיוני גראמי מופיעים באחד על References?
כולם לכאורה מאה אחוז. יוני גרם Precision נשמע לא רע.
מצד שני, יש פה משהו שאולי קצת גורם לנו להרגשת אי נוחות. נכון?
וזאת למה? בגלל שבעצם, למרות שזה זה בעצם אותו אחד מופיע ב References, אין אף רפרנס שבו זה הופיע יותר מאשר פעם אחת.
אוקיי, אז בעצם אנחנו. אנחנו לא רוצים לתת.
אם במשפט מסוים יש חזרות, כן, יש מולטי פליסיטי של איזשהו n גרם, אז לא מספיק לנו שכדי לקבל את מלוא הניקוד על אותו אינגרם, לא מספיק לנו?
אינגרם הזה יופיע באחד ה References.
כדי לקבל את מלוא הניקוד הוא צריך להופיע כמספר הזה של פעמים לפחות באחד References.
אוקיי,
אז בגלל זה אם תשימו לב הכוכבית פה אומרת היא Fan gram appears multiple times new account mode and maximum number times is a part in any of the effect.
זה דרך הפורמלית להגיד את מה שאמרתי עכשיו כן הייתה שאלה.
זה נשמע די מתקבל על הדעת. נכון צריך את הכוכבית הזאת ולתקן שם איזה באג, אבל אנחנו מקבלים את הדפים השונים ומחשבים את הממוצע ההנדסי על.
על כן על יוני גרם באג גרם trigger בדק מה חסר בסיפור הזה.
אולי מישהו יכול כבר לראות את זה? מה המדד הזה כפי שהוא עכשיו?
חסר בצורה זועקת? כן, אפשר לעטוף סרט, יכול לעשות את כל המילים שיהיו בדיוק לגמרי סגירות.
אז בעצם רגע, אתה אומר את כל המילים אני רוצה לעשות, לא References קבועים.
אין לך גישה לרופא סקס? הסקר שיכול לעזור לך לעשות הרבה מאוד דברים.
אגב, במטרה לנסות לצמצם את הקשיים, את האפשרות לקבל ציונים גבוהים בקריירה.
אוקיי, אז מה תעשה אז? אוקיי, אז אתה אומר you can play this מטריקס? אבל איך?
תהיה קצת יותר מדויק? רגע, לשאול את עצמי מה אתה רוצה?
מה אתה רוצה? אתה בעצם רוצה שמה שאתה מכניס לקנדידה האנגרים שהכנסת פנימה יופיעו בלפחות אחד מאלה?
נכון? כן. אבל לא אכפת לך מי הם גורמים שנמצאים ב References ושאתה לא הכנסת פנימה.
נכון, אתה לא נענש עליהם בשבת? אז מה תעשה עכשיו?
כך. בסוף הסיפור להוסיף את הסיפור של אז רגע, להוסיף הרבה יכניס אותי לבעיות כי אני צריך לצדוק בכולם.
אני דווקא אמצא משהו שאני ממש בטוח בו ואוציא רק אותו.
אוקיי, נגיד שמופיע שם. לא יודע מה דונלד טראמפ.
אז אני אומר היי יופי, את זה אני יודע לתרגם מעולה.
יש רק תרגום אחד אפשרי לדונלד טראמפ. זה דונלד טראמפ בעברית ואני כותב אותו.
ועכשיו קיבלתי. יוני גרם by גראם וטרי גראם Precision מושלמים כי באמת זה מופיע לפחות באחד References, כנראה בכולם.
אבל זה נשמע תרגום די גרוע. נכון, בהנחה שהמשפט המקור הכיל עוד כמה דברים חוץ מהשם של נשיא ארצות הברית.
אוקיי, אז מה אני יכול לעשות? אני יכול לתת.
כן, זה פשוט דוגמה. אני יכול לתת.
Gravity panel. אוקיי, אתם נענשים אם אתם יצרניים מדי?
כן, תפרטו Brief איך אתם עושים את זה?
אז בעצם הנקודה היא כזאת מה שעושים זה באיזושהי דרך.
אנחנו רוצים לתת עונש על קנדידה סטים שהם יותר קצרים מהרף.
הצורה המקובלת לעשות את זה זה עם עונש אקספוננציאלי כאילו עונש גיאומטרי עדיין סופג קנס, סופג קנס של כך וכך אחוזים.
לכל מילה שאני מוסיף מיותרת.
פחות או יותר זה פחות או יותר מה שאמרתי עכשיו. לא בדיוק זה E בחזקת 1 מינוס r חלקי C.
כלומר אני מכפיל באיזשהו גורם כפלי כן שהולך ונהיה יותר.
שבעצם הולך ונהיה יותר קרוב ל.
וככל שהקרדיט יותר ארוך אני בעצם לא נעים יותר גדול מהר.
אני לא נענש אם הוא בדיוק בגודל של R אז אחד פחות אחד.
אני גם לא נענש. כן, אבל אם הוא כבר יותר קצר מ reference אז אני כן נענש.
כן, משהו שהוא לא כן, לא בדיוק ליניארי, באורך של כמה שפספסתי, לא בדיוק גיאומטרי בכמה שפספסתי אלא באחד חלקי זה.
אז אם נגיד הרפרנס היה באורך 10 והקרדיט שלי הוא נגיד באורך לא יודע מה 20 אז זה אומר שהיחס ביניהם הוא חצי כן,
מה שאומר שאני ייענש בפקטור של אני ייענש בפקטור של 1.
שנייה. R חלקי C הוא לא חצי הוא 2. אם.
בלבלתי את עצמי. אם הרפרנס הוא באורך 20 ואני ניחשתי משהו באורך 10.
כן, כי אם זה היה ההפך לא הייתי נענש. לא נענש על להיות ארוך מדי, קצר מדי.
אז אם הרפרנס הוא באורך 20 והקרדיט באורך 10 אז היחס ביניהם יהיה 2 ואז אני יענש בחזקת מינוס 1.
אוקיי, התוצאה שלי תוכפל באחד חלקי.
אז בעצם זה מחשב?
כמה מסתכל על היחס הזה ובודק את הסטייה, אבל אתם יכולים לשאול שאלה המיידית שאולי אתם יכולים לשאול את עצמכם, אבל מה אם לא כל ה References באותו אורך?
לפי מה אני נענש? כן. אז מה שעושים זה קצת.
זה כבר תלוי במימוש של בלוג. בגדול מה שהוא עושה זה מנסה למצוא את הקנדידה, את הקנדידה, את הרפרנס הכי דומה לקנדידה.
כן, זה אדי דיסטנס או משהו כזה מתאים באיזושהי צורה להכי דומה ואז לוקח אותו לצרכי העורך.
כלומר מבחינת הקונספט. כן מבחינת האורך כן. כאילו אם יש לך רפרנס באורך 15 זה בערך 17 אז הוא יבדוק למה רפרנס יותר דומה?
איזה רפרנס. הקנדידה יותר דומה וייקח אותו. אפשר גם את האמצע אפשר בדרך כלל לוקחים אחד.
כן. בסדר. אז כן.
אז פה נתתי גם כל מיני דוגמאות. בגדול מחשבים את היוני גרם Precision הטבעי, גרם Precision את TRI גרם Precision וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
מזה מחשבים את הבלו Score על ידי ממוצע גיאומטרי ואז מכפילים את זה.
Private term. מעניש אותנו עם ה reference הקרוב ביותר הוא יותר ארוך.
כן בגדול הגרסה הפשוטה הזאת של המטריקה כבר בהרבה מאוד מקרים נותנת איזושהי אינדיקציה לגבי איכות.
כן, בהרבה מקרים הצליחו להראות שיש קורלציה בין הבלו Score לבין Human Evaluation, בייחוד כש.
וצריך להסביר באיזה הקשרים כן. אז הכוונה להקשרים שבהם.
א. אתם משווים בין מערכות שונות? כן, אז זה בדרך כלל לא נותן קורלציה טובה.
אם אתם משווים בין אאוטפיטים שונים של אותה מערכת.
בסדר, זה בדרך כלל אינדיקציה פחות טובה או פריטים שונים של אותה מערכת או אאוט, או השוואה בין בין תרגום.
תרגומים של אנשים שונים. גם שם הקורלציה היא לא כל כך טובה.
כן, אבל בהרבה מקרים של השוואה בין מערכות שונות זה נתן קורלציה טובה.
כשיש לכם מספיק דוגמאות כאן, אז זה גם חשוב לומר המגמה היא לא.
אין קורלציה כל כך טובה פר דוגמה. כן, פר דוגמה פר משפט.
אבל אם אתם עושים אגרגציה על פני הרבה, כלומר יש לכם מערכת אחת מערכת 2 זאת נתתם לה לתרגם אלף משפטים ולזאת אתם נתתם לתרגם 1000 משפטים.
עכשיו יש לכם 1000 תרגומים ממקור אחד 1000 תרגומים מקור 2.
בסדר. חישבתי את ה score של כל אחד, מאה אלף פה וכל אחד מאלף כאן על score הממוצע של המערכת הזאת בהשוואה לבלוק הממוצע של המערכת הזאת,
יתנו אינדיקציה טובה לגבי הסט Engagement הממוצע של המערכת הזאת לעומת המערכת הזאת.
אבל כאן חשוב לשים מאוד לב לסדר המתאים.
לסטטיסטיקה כן. כי זה לא שהדבר שאני אמרתי עכשיו לא נובע,
וככלל זה ממש לא יהיה המקרה שאם נגיד אתם רוצים לראות איזה 100 תרגומים מתוך 10000 של אותה מערכת הם יותר טובים, לא?
רעיון טוב בכלל. להשוות את הבלוז score כן לא score על משפטים שונים sources שונים.
Not compatible to one another. כן, זה לא יתן לכם טוב אם אתם בודקים מישהו מכאן ומישהו מכאן מאותו Soul Sentence.
אבל עכשיו יש לכם רק output אחד של כל מערכת. גם לא תקבלו קורלציה טובה כי Variant הוא עצום.
כן Variant הוא ענק. תעשו ממוצע על פני 1000 משפטים מא מב תקבלו כבר הרבה פעמים כל הארץ הסבירה.
אוקיי, אז צריך מאוד לשים לב והרבה פעמים אנשים עשו שטויות נוראיות עם בלו סקור.
כן הסתמכו עליו כדי לטעון טענות שמעולם לא עשו לו ולידציה, כמו למשל בדברים שאמרתי לכם עכשיו שככלל לא רואים בהם אפקט, אז חשוב מאוד לשים לב.
אבל אפילו אם לוקחים ומפעילים את בלו סקור בצורה מושכלת, כמובן שיש לו כל מיני בעיות.
כן, אחת הבעיות. אחת הבעיות שבעצם הוא מתמודד איתו ונדבר עליו בשיעור, אולי אפילו נספיק היום או בשבוע הבא.
זה בעצם זה שהוא מאוד רגיש למילים המסוימות שמשתמשים בהן נכון?
Which is במילים שונות לגמרי.
נכון, מילים נרדפות לא לוקח בחשבון פרפראזה, לא לוקחת בחשבון או אפילו לא לוקח בחשבון איזה מילים הם הם.
לא יודע מה מילות יחס שאולי הרבה פעמים משתנות בין תרגום לתרגום ואיזה לא.
הוא מאוד Strict. הדבר היחידי שאפשר לעשות כדי להתגבר על זה זה פשוט לתת לו כמה References ואז לקוות שה References יכסו משהו.
בגלל זה עדיין השיטה הכי כאמור הגולד סטנדרטית או מה שהכי קרוב לזה זה השיטה של Human Evaluation.
ומי שמתעניין לראות איך עושים את זה, איך מבצעים בין מתייגים אנושיים שונים.
אז אני מפנה אתכם למאמר הזה מ 2015, שהוא הפרוטוקול הסטנדרטי.
הוא מסתמך על Crowd sourcing. למי שמתעניין. שמעתם על המושג של outsourcing?
מישהו יכול להסביר מה זה? עבדות מודרנית?
הגדרות נוספות? לתת לאנשים לקיים ליצור data science תמיד משתמשים.
אוקיי, אז מה ההבדל בין זה לבין לשכור אנשים שיעבדו כעובדים במעבדה שלי על המושגים האלו?
כן, אז יש כל מיני פלטפורמות כאלה כמו אמאזון מכאניקה Turk והיה crowd flower ויש כל מיני דברים כאלה שבהם יש זמין.
הם קוראים לזה שוק. כן, שוק חלטורות כזה שבו אנשים מפרסמים עבודות, או אם אני מציע כך וכך כסף פר דוגמה.
אנשים עושים את זה. מטבע הדברים זה רועש. מנסים לעשות איזשהו קוואליטי שורץ על המציגים, אבל הרבה פעמים זה לא קל.
אבל מצד שני זה נורא קל להרים פרויקט כזה אם זה לא שפה, אם זו שפה שמדברים אותה.
הרבה אנשים בייחוד מדברים אותה הרבה אנשים בעולם המערבי, אבל לא רק יוכלו מאוד מהר לעשות את זה.
במקום להתחיל להוציא קול קורא לזכור מתייגים טה טה טה טה טה.
ויש כמובן גם ביקורת על זה. מצד שני, כי אומרים שמשלמים שכר נמוך ביחס למה שמקובל בארץ שממנה מעסיקים.
כן, זאת אומרת, אולי בן אדם מהודו מוכן לעבוד בשביל כמעט כלום במושגים של כלכלה מערבית, אבל זה לא בהכרח אומר שזה ראוי לעשות.
יש גם על זה הרבה דיון. אז זו שאלה איך עושים את זה בצורה אתית ולא ניכנס אליה כאן.
אוקיי. יפה.
נמשיך. נושא הבא שלנו שהוא free training ו context.
בן שלום. שאלה כן. איך אנחנו אוספים את הטקסטים, בעצם?
את הטקסטים, את References? כן. אז בדרך כלל אתה.
בשביל הדבר הזה אתה בדרך כלל כן. אתה.
אוקיי, נפריד את השאלה הזאת לכמה. לפעמים ה References הם פשוט דברים שקיימים כי תזכור References להבדיל מדרגת Assessment.
זאת אומרת, להבדיל מהמקרה שבו אתה צריך לתת תרגום מכונה לאיזשהו בן אדם ולשאול אותו האם זה טוב או לא.
טוב שמטבע הדברים זה לא מידע שפשוט נמצא שם, כי לא בטוח שמישהו אי פעם הציע את התרגום הזה כתרגום,
או שטרח לספר למישהו References זה פשוט תרגומים טובים שאתה סומך עליהם של איזשהו טקסט.
אוקיי, אז הם מאוד Reuse Bold.
כן, זאת אומרת, גם אם זה עולה לא מעט לייצר סט כזה עבור איזשהו אוסף משפטים זה מאוד reuse able, כי אתה עכשיו יכול להשתמש באותו סט של References,
לבדוק המון המון המון מערכות שונות זה בשונה מה דיירקט Assessment, כן או השיפוטים האנושיים שבכל output חדש של מערכת אתה צריך לבדוק אותו.
אוקיי, אז לפעמים באמת שוכרים מתרגמים מקצועיים ועושים את זה.
ואומנם זה עולה איזשהו סכום, אבל בגלל שעושים את זה פעם אחת ואז זה משמש אז זה עדיין יוצא שזה שווה את זה.
אבל לפעמים גם פשוט יש סטים קיימים של כן, זה תלוי מה הדומיין שלך כמובן, אבל יש פשוט דברים שהם מתורגמים ברמה טובה.
לא כי מישהו רצה לבדוק מערכות machine translation, אלא פשוט זה תרגום שהוא קיים מאיזושהי סיבה.
כן, אולי זה. כן, ספר שתורגם כמה פעמים לשפה אחרת.
אם אתה מתעניין בזה, אולי זה Manual שתורגם על ידי חברה מאוד רצינית שמאוד בודקת את כן צריך להיזהר כי לא כל המניות מתורגמים בצורה טובה.
כפי שאולי חלקכם שמתם לב, אבל כאילו יש פשוט לפעמים מקורות טובים ואמינים שאתה יכול להסתמך עליהם גם.
כן. אוקיי. אוקיי, אז Connection is wedding ב.
Actually יזמות עם Wedding זה בעצם הייתי אומר שהייתה המהפכה הגדולה שהביאו איתה, שהביאו אותה מודלי השפה הגדולים.
אז ההתחלה שלהם הייתה בעצם סביב Machine Translation.
כפי שציינתי, ה Transformer Attention Unit זה בעצם מאמר על Machine translation.
לפני כן, הרבה מההתקדמות בתחום הזה של סיקוונס הסיקוונס הייתה סביב Machine Translation, אבל בעצם די מהר הבינו שאפשר לעשות עם ארכיטקטורות האלה הרבה יותר.
בעצם, אפשר להשתמש בהם להמון משימות NLP, וזאת על ידי שימוש ברעיון הזה שנקרא קונטקסט שעולה ויורד עם Padding או עם Padding, שאותו נסביר עכשיו.
אז הרעיון הוא שבעצם אם NLP, כפי שלמדנו אותו כאן וכפי שהוא היה מוכר לקהילה עד 2017, סדר גודל אז התחיל להשתנות.
היה פשוט שיש לנו פיצ'רים שאו שקבענו אותם ידנית.
כן, באיזשהו אופן נכון כמו שעשינו בשיעורים הראשונים בקורס.
או שאולי כן למדנו אותם כ class סטרים ביחס לכל מיני שיטות של שינויים ב things.
או אולי כן או אולי סקיפ גרם ודברים כאלה, אבל בגדול הפיצ'רים האלה זה היה משהו.
גם אם לא הבנו מה בדיוק אומר? כן.
מה בדיוק אומר את כל קואורדינטות בסקייפ גרם כי זה פשוט איזה שהן מטריצות.
כן, איזשהם מטריצות שהוא למד. בכל זאת הבנו שזה איזשהו פיצ'ר שמתאים למילה הזאת והזאת שמייצג באיזשהו מובן את ההתפלגות שלה על פני קשרים רבים,
וזה דחוס באיזושהי צורה על ידי הסקייפ, כמודל או על ידי Pca או על ידי כל טכניקה אחרת שהשתמשנו בה להורדת מימד.
אבל. אבל המגבלה בפיצ'רים האלה זה שאולי זה לא הפיצ'רים שאותם אנחנו צריכים באיזשהו הקשר מסוים.
למה? כי כן, כבר דיברנו על זה. אפילו כשדיברנו על כי manual Features.
אז בכלל, מה הסיכוי שאני בדיוק כלל לא יודע מה הפיצ'ר לפיצ'ר הכי טוב שאני לא יודע לאוסף הפיצ'רים הכי
טוב שיספיק לי איזשהו וישקול לינארי שלהם ואז אני אקבל ביצועים טובים אם אפשר לקבל יותר מזה.
עם deep net וזה אתם כבר מכירים. ואפילו במקרה של במקרה של non context של וורדים Buildings של דברים כמו כמו סקיפ גרהאם.
אז דיברנו על זה. נכון, למילים יכולות להיות יכולים להיות מובנים, שונים,
ואז יכול להיות שאני לא רוצה לקחת איזשהו Representation איזשהו ייצוג שמבוסס על סך כל המופעים של דוג בקורפוס,
כי חלק מהם הם חלק מהודו, וחלק מהם הם כלב וחלק מהם לא יודע מין כינוי פמילי קארי כזה בין לא יודע צעירים,
קבוצות מסוימות, כל מיני דברים כאלה כן או חלק מדג פייט.
נכון שזה בכלל קרב בין נכון טייסי קרב וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
יש הרבה סוגים של דוג ולמה שאני אעשה לכולם אגרגציה ביחד?
אמרנו? מעבר לזה, אפילו אחרי שחילקו, אז לכאורה הייתי יכול אולי לנסות לייצר עם Padding לכל מובן של המילה.
אבל בעצם מה זה מובן של מילה? מתי שתי מילים מתי?
שני מופעים הם במובן אחר. כן נתנו את הדוגמה של דג נכון?
האם דג שמופיע אצלי בצלחת או במחבת הוא אותו מובן של דג כמו דג שאני רואה בים?
כן, יש בהחלט קשר בין שני המובנים האלה, אבל לא ברור שאותם תכונות באות לידי ביטוי בשני המקרים,
וכנראה שרבות מהתכונות הם רלוונטיות מאוד שונות, ולכן הייתי רוצה בעצם לעשות קונטקסט דואליסטית.
כן, הייתי רוצה לעשות סטריליזציה, וכדי לעשות את זה אני לא רוצה פשוט להשתמש.
אני לא רוצה להשתמש בלייבל Data. כן? כלומר, אני לא רוצה להשתמש בדאטה שציינתי עבור המשימה הספציפית שאני עכשיו מנסה לפתור.
Party speech staging או וואטאבר? Static pricing או information expression או machine translation.
בגלל שהדברים האלה שמבוססים על מאמץ אנושי הם תמיד מוגבלים.
כן, אין לי כמויות אדירות שלהם, אבל מצד שני הרבה פעמים אוסף הקטגוריות שלי הוא לא קטן,
בייחוד כשמה שאני מייצר זה Token ואז ה soft max הוא על גודל אוצר המילים, ולכן אני רוצה לעשות שימוש בדאטה שקיים בכמויות הן בכמויות מאוד גדולות.
והשאלה איך עושים את זה? השאלה איך עושים את זה? אז הרעיון שבעצם מאחורי הקונטקסט של זה שאני יכול להשתמש באותן באותה נוי real machinery.
כן, באותם מודלים. בהתחלה זה התחיל עם Running. כן עם running language models.
אחרי זה זה המשיך ל Transformers. אבל בגדול הרעיון שם אותו רעיון.
הרעיון הוא איך אני יכול להשתמש בדאטה שקיים לי בכמויות אדירות כדי ללמוד ייצוגים או כדי ללמוד פיצ'רים או כדי ללמוד.
כן, איזה שהם קונטקסט Police Dimensions שיותאמו ספציפית לחליפה לפי המידה של כל משפט ומשפט וכל מילה ומילה לפי הקונטקסט שבו היא מופיעה.
אוקיי, אז בואו נצא להפסקה ואז נסביר מהי הדרך המקובלת לעשות את זה.
אוקיי. משפט.
אתה יודע מה אתה רוצה כבר לשמוע? אני?
רוצה. לשחרר!
אותך? ואני חושב שאתה משוגע.
את רוצה לפגוש אותך? בתוך החברה הזאת?
לא כמו שהיה נהוג בעבר בעיראק.
בכל שלב בחיים יש שתי דמויות בעיצוב נבילה.
לא משנה באיזה בשיתוף פעולה, ואתה אומר הייתי אולי מנסה לעשות את זה בכל מובן של המילה, ואפילו שזה באותו מובן מה זה מובן מאליו.
לא קשה. מאוד עדינה. הייתי רוצה להתאים את זה למופע הספציפי שלי.
תודה רבה. הכניסה חופשית.
כן, אז עכשיו זה רק לפתוח את זה?
רק אם אתה מסתכל על זה, אבל ספציפית אנחנו כל הזמן בשיעור הקודם.
בואו נדבר על סיפורים. כאלה.
היינו אמורים להיות מוזמנים לפנות אלינו את רמת הסיכון ללקות בשבץ מוחי.
מה יקרה מטבע הדברים? אני לא חושב שזה כל כך טוב.
לא לא לא, זה לא היה אצל מנהיגים מדללי דם.
זה אומר יחסית טוב את הטיפול, לא. אתה חושב שהבעיה לא?
הוא הראה את הבלוג כן רענן, אבל הוא שחור על גבי שנים ללא תמונות.
איפה הייתי? בשנה שעברה, בקו האחרון בפרשה שלנו.
אולי אתה כותב? אין דבר כזה. אתה לא רוצה לשנות את התפיסה שלך?
לא לא לא לא לא, לא רק בירושלים. עכשיו זה בדיוק הזמן.
עכשיו יודע מה צריך לחזור שוב לזה?
אבל אז לא הבנתי לאן נעלמתי.
אולי אולי זאת הייתה הבעיה. אז תודה רבה. 79 כבר הספקתי לשלוח את 79 במו ידיי שביקש להספיק.
לא חושב שזה לא בסדר. הקבוצה בדרך כלל לא תעשה זאת.
המבחן של השנה אולי שונה במקרה של שנה שעברה.
בבית חולים כבר לא יפסיקו לדבר.
ואני אומרת. היה לי ברור אז העניין הוא מאוד שזה כמו שלכל דבר אומרים לך סמסטר א, אבל זה בסדר.
ועכשיו מסקנות לגבי. סטודנט נכון, אבל אכן לא יכולתי לקחת כאלו חלקים.
כן בסך.
הכל לא הרגשתי שאני צריכה ואף לא חייבת לעמוד בעניין הזה.
לא. פתחתי את ההרצאה.
בשביל זה? מה? אתה לובש?
צורה של סבר פנים כמו שאתה עצמך. כן.
מה נשמע? לא צריך לעשות את זה, זה בטוח שזה היה טוב.
זה היה טוב. יאללה בסדר. זה לא היה.
זה לא שאני חושב שהוא לא ירצה אותך.
אני מוצאת עצמי. מזמן צריכה ללמוד הרצאה.
לא צריך ללמוד לא בבית ולא מצאתיו. קצת על האנשים של אליזבת.
מחר אנחנו מספרים שושלת עכשיו.
אני דווקא לא משתמש בו מספיק טוב.
אני לא סגרתי את הדלת עכשיו. מה שמסביב. לא, לא לא, לא זה.
לא. היה ברגע הראשון.
אבל תקשיב, אני חושב על זה, כי באנגליה של כיתה של 220 שבו 147 זה יותר מדי פעם.
זה משהו שדורש הרבה מאמץ.
זה משהו שאתם עושים ביום הראשון יש שם.
עם ביל קלינטון בוודאות. יש גם גרסה פיזית של חברת התרופות עבור חברים מכל מיני קבוצות של ילדים עושה סקס אחר, אבל הערב.
היא חושבת שצריך. להמשיך הלאה, אבל בעצם צריך להיות מבוסס על משהו שהוא כבר לא יותר פשוט בתור משהו אחר.
אני לא יודעת איך אני הייתי מורידה את הנושא של המציאות, איך הוא היה.
עושה? אותך?
שעברה יותר מאשר זו התשובה שלו.
מדובר במספר סגנונות לא צנועים של המוצרים שלנו.
2 באוקטובר 2015. אני מקווה.
שכעת יש לך קצת סבלנות כשאתה עובר תקופה מסוימת של ניסיון יוסף על האירוע שלך.
זה. לא עניין של טעם וריח.
אני לא בטוח עד כמה היא מושפעת. שמעתי כבר לא צריך לפרסם.
אתה מבקש מאוד שיפרסמו את האפשרות לפרסם את עצמן.
חשבתי על זה יותר ועכשיו יש לנו את הלימודים שלנו, שלנו בוואטסאפ של יש להם קבוצות של השני של המתרס לא ראיתי צורך מפורסמים לעלות לבמה.
לא כן? זאת אומרת כן כן כן זה.
לא יפה. 2. כן.
כן. כן בסדר. אני בעיקר מזכירה לעצמי שלא משנה מה אתה רוצה לעשות בחיים שלך צריך לצאת לחופשי.
אני יכולה. להגיד לך אולי החיסרון?
אני לא רואה איך זה קשור לעובדה שלי.
אבל יש אנשים בעולם. שלא כל כך פשוט.
לא אמרתי כלום. רק שלושה חודשים בעבודה שציירתי במסגרת הקמפיין.
ואז אמרתי שלושה אנשים צריכים לרצות במיוחד צריך להיות בטוח בעצמך מה לעשות, אבל היה מסוגל לעשות הרבה יותר פשוט כדי ליצור את אותו הדבר רק עבור כל אחד.
וחצי קיבלתי הרבה כסף על אבא שלי.
אני מצטער לומר דבר, אבל ברגע שיש כאלה שאתה עושה ספורט בגלל שהם מספקים לך את המוצר שלך, מידע שימושי בסופו.
של דבר זה המוצר שלי. אני לא אשכח איך זה יצא החוצה מהארץ.
ככה זה זמן. מצוין.
למה שלא רוצים לעשות?
סקס? כן.
האירוע חייב. להיות מושלם!
אנחנו. מסוגלים לעשות כך?
במשך זמן מה לעשות את מה שאני צריכה לעשות.
דרך המחשב בכל דרך אפשרית. סוציאליזציה הנה מה זה מטופש.
אפשר לראות את זה תמיד, את הפוטנציאל העצום הטמון.
בכל. סיפור שמע לשבור.
כאילו נראה לי עכשיו אני צריך להגיש תוכנית מגירה.
לא צריך לדבר על שתי מדינות כבר חמש שנים.
כל אחד צריך להרגיש חלק מהתרבות אדיר של יהודי בארץ הזו.
ואז יש כל כך. הרבה אנשים חושבים איך זה בהחלט יכול להיות חבר כנסת.
זה מה שנקרא ראשוני של הקבוצה החדשה.
אם אתם צריכים לפתוח בלוג אז אני לא צריך לעשות לכם סיפור.
זה דורש הרבה. דווקא שחקן טוב.
זו בעיה קצת יותר קשה. בהצלחה!
להמשך הכתבה לחץ כאן. כל חודש הפועל תל אביב.
אתה בסדר גמור. רוצה? שהתגובות שלך יעלו?
אני חושב שזה לא היה נכון. אחרי ההפסד מחוץ למשרד החוץ.
נכתב בנושא שאלות למחשבה. לחץ כאן.
הכל טוב, הכל טוב לא להיכנס לשטח. לפני חצי שנה פלוס מינוס לשלוח עכשיו לא יכול להיות בעיה בזמן.
עכשיו אני אסביר. איך זה?
יכול? להיות שזה פשוט כל כך הרבה דברים טובים?
אבל זה מה שאתה צריך. לעשות טוב מאוד.
שלום. אני יודע שזה קשה לשחק את המשחק.
כן כן כן.
אני מצטער, אבל אתה לא ממש מבין למה אתה לא מצליח לישון על השטיח.
לא מבינה איך זה. לא אומר שאתה.
זכור שאתה צריך להיות חלק מהמשחק.
אני לא רואה בעיה אבל זה לא אומר. שאתה לא יודע אבל גמישות מסוימת.
עכשיו על הבטן שלך. עכשיו תסתכלו על זה.
זה היה גם בכפר. סבא.
אז בואו נתחיל. אם אתם מחפשים את. השמלה המושלמת בעסק של רגע אחד של לחץ.
אני לא יודע למה, אבל תמיד אפשר לשמוע על החיים שלהם לבקר בהם.
אין סיבה שלא. 2 אתה קונה משהו שאתה לא צריך לקחת בחשבון החדש?
כן, זה היה צריך למצוא עבודה. כן, שירותים, תכשיטים היה צורך מיידי במשך שנים.
כן כן, הייתי מסוגל לצאת מהבית. זה לא הולך ביחד. לא צריך להיות שחקן.
מפתח. אשמח לשמוע חוות.
דעת. חוות דעת אחת יכולה להצליח.
לא מצליח? כן כן. לא?
כן, אני חושב שזו השקעה. אדירה.
חלק תיאורטי לוקח חלק.
לא. מבוטל של אנשים.
אבל. כשאתה נותן לעצמך שאתה רואה את התרגיל הזה.
זה לא. מיד כן.
אם אתה רוצה לעסוק בהגדרה עצמית עכשיו אתה צריך.
לעשות. משהו עכשיו?
אוקיי. בסדר.
אז בעצם השאלה היא איך אנחנו יכולים להשתמש בתבנית הלייבל דאטה שממנה יש לנו בכמויות,
יחד עם כוח חישוב ומודלים חזקים וגדולים, כדי לקבל ביצועים טובים יותר בשלל משימות.
אז הרעיון אפשר בעצם לחשוב עליו כאיזשהו הכללה של הרעיון שראינו בהקשר של של סקיפ גרהם מודל.
סליחה שזה בעצם הרעיון של מה שלפעמים קוראים Self supervision.
כן, או. או במילים אחרות מה שהדבר הזה אומר זה שאנחנו עכשיו ניקח איזשהו מודל נורמלי.
המודל הזה אנחנו נלמד אותו לעשות איזשהו גזל ירי Task, איזושהי משימה שהיא בעצם משימה על אן לייבל Data, אבל היא משימה שהיא לא היא לכשעצמה לא ממש מעניינת.
זאת אומרת, היא לא באמת המטרה שלנו. היא לא באמת המטרה שלנו אין.
אבל מצד אחד יש לנו הרבה מידע עבורה כי היא מסתמכת רק על אן לייבל Data.
ומצד שני המידע הזה הוא מידע שעשוי להיות רב ערך לכל מיני משימות שונות.
למה אני אומר שזאת הכללה של הרעיון שראינו בסקייפ כמודל?
כי גם בסקייפ, גם מודל. אם אתם זוכרים מה שאמרנו זה אנחנו ננסה בהינתן מילה לחזות את השכנים.
נכון, לחזות את השכנים. זה משהו שאפשר לעשות מ לייבל Data. כן, לראות איזה מילים אחרות הן שכנות של אותה מילה.
המשימה הזאת לכשעצמה היא לא ממש מעניינת. כן, לא נראה לא.
לא חושב שמשתמשים בה יותר מדי לכשעצמה.
אבל אם אני יודע את אם אני יודע לעשות את המשימה הזאת, כנראה שעל הדרך למדתי כל מיני ייצוגים אפקטיביים של הבעיה, כי אחרת לא הייתי מצליח לפתור את המשימה.
אוקיי, אז אנחנו צריכים למצוא בעיה שמצד אחד אפשר ללמוד אותה על לייבל טקסט, ללמוד אותה.
מאן לייבל טקסט. מצד שני, שכדי לפתור אותה צריך על הדרך לפתור כל מיני משימות שהן מעניינות.
כן. ולכן אנחנו יכולים להניח שמודל שמסוגל לבצע את המשימה הזאת גם ייצג את המידע הזה באיזושהי צורה אפקטיבית.
ספציפית. כן, הגישה של הקונטקסט של World in Beings היא מסתמכת במקום עם קונטקסט של List עם Weddings כמו Skype Groups היו מבוססות על מין Bgu Words.
נכון, בהינתן מילה בואו נחזיר מילה שנמצאת באזור שלה במקרה הקונטקסט Police.
מה שאנחנו מנסים לעשות זה בעצם סוג של language Modeling.
כן? כלומר, בהינתן חלק מהמילים במשפט, לחזות מילים אחרות במשפט אוקיי, אז זה כבר לא שכן כלשהו,
משהו שנמצא בחלון מסביב, אלא ממש לחזות את בחלק מהמקרים את המילה הבאה, או את המילה החסרה או דברים מהסוג הזה.
ותכף נראה למה. זה אולי רעיון טוב? כי כפי שאנחנו כבר היינו קצת דוגמאות ונראה גם עכשיו language modeling.
בעצם, כדי לעשות אותה טוב צריך לדעת הרבה מאוד דברים.
צריך למשל לדעת Grammar. כן. הנה סתם דוגמה פשוטה זה וזה.
כן. איך אני אדע מתי יש? מתי לחזות Ben ומתי לחזות בבן אם אני יודע מה ההבדל הסמנטי או לא, משנה באיזה הקשרים כל אחד מהם מופיע ואיך עובד הדקדוק שלהם,
זה מאוד פשוט, נכון ו A זה של השוואה וזה אם אי זה של אז או ש או דברים כאלה.
כן, אבל אני צריך לדעת את זה כי אחרת אני אטעה במשימה הזאת שהיא תת בעיה קטנה של language modeling the same ויועציה.
כן, זה בעיה אחרת. איך אני? איך אני אדע?
עדה. באיזה? איך להשלים משפט נתון?
אני צריך כנראה לדעת באיזה מובן המילים משמשות, כי אחרת אני עשוי לטעות.
למשל טוב, זה דוגמה קצת מלאכותית, אבל פשוט כדי להדגים לכם נגיד אתם עכשיו מסתכלים על מודל שפה והוא צריך לחזור את המילה הבאה במשפט הזה.
1 out of the words, crying palace excavations host and a prayer Approaches is.
כן, ומה שצריך לחזות כאן זה שזה public class.
עכשיו תשימו לב שהדוגמה הזאת היא דוגמה נחמדה בגלל שגם לכאורה המילה train היא לא קשורה לעץ.
היא גם סוג של ציפור. אולי היא לא נורא שונה מהסכנה. היא שהוא פלא.
כן, אבל בהקשר כאן למה היא לא המילה שצריך לחזות?
לא יודע, אולי כן בדיוק, כי בעצם יש לה שני מובנים, אחד כ עגורן ואחד כ עגור.
וכן לא אדום. אולי זו דוגמה, קצת קונטרה, אבל הרעיון כאן בדוגמא הזאת הייתה שיש כאן שתי מילים שהן מילים שהן שמות של ציפורים,
עגור וטכנאי, אבל אחד מהם הוא מכשיר הרמה גם במובן אחר שלו Crane כן.
ושאר הדברים כאן. שאר הדברים כאן הם גם מיני ציוד מכני.
אבל פלג כן, לא. אין לו את המובן הזה. אז בעצם צריך לעשות פה איזשהו היסק שמתבסס על הבנה של כמה מובנים של איזה מובן שהמילה Crane נמצא פה בשימוש?
אוקיי, אז בסדר, זה אולי דוגמה קצת country, אבל חשבתי שהיא נחמדה.
General practical knowledge.
גם זה כדי לחזות את המילה הבאה צריך לדעת גם כל מיני מידע על העולם, או לאו דווקא על העולם, אבל לפחות על איך שבדרך כלל אנשים מתארים את העולם.
כן, נגיד, שמות בירה של מדינות זה כנראה משהו שלרוב לא יהיה יותר מדי ויכוח.
אולי יש כמה מדינות שיש להן כמה ערי בירה, נכון, אבל.
אבל גם אז אוקיי, לא משנה, אבל אין מה אאוטליין נכון כמו דרום אפריקה, אבל רוב המדינות יש להם בירה אחת והם יודעים אותה יודעים לחזות את המילה הבאה ולהפך.
אדם יודע לחזות את המילה הבאה בהקשרים האלה. אז אני יודע מה?
הרי הבירה pair Facing כן. Instead to say you can not the green where you can say?
אז אפשר אפילו באמצעות ה Template הזה. לכאורה אם אני יודע להמשיך כן.
אם אני language מזל מספיק טוב. אני גם יודע לעשות פרפראזה והרבה מאוד דברים כאלה.
אז language modeling. נראה שכדי לעשות אותו טוב צריך לדעת המון המון דברים מסוגים שונים על איך עובדת שפה נחווה תחביר שלה ואוצר המילים שלה על איך?
על כל מיני פרטים. Faculty או נטיות של אנשים לומר דברים מסוימים ולא אחרים וכן הלאה וכן הלאה זו משימה מאוד עשירה.
אז מה נעשה אם ככה? אז אוקיי, אז עכשיו הדרך קדימה ברורה.
אנחנו ניקח מלא מלא אן לייבל טקסט נבנה מודלי שפה או דברים דומים למגדלי שפה.
כן, דברים שחוזים תחזיות על בסיס אן לייבל Data.
ניקח המון המון דאטה מרחבי האינטרנט, נאסוף טריליוני טוקנים ויותר נאמן את המודלים האלה, ואם הם יצליחו סך הכל במשימה שלהם,
אז כנראה שעל הדרך הם למדו גם הרבה דברים על המון דברים שימושיים שאולי אנחנו יכולים להשתמש בהם בהקשרים אחרים.
וזה הרעיון של Free train. למה זה נקרא free training?
תכף נבין. הרעיון בעצם אומר, הוא בעצם מתייחס לפרדיגמה שנקראת Pre Training and fine Tuning, שאני לא יודע אם דנתי בה בקורסים אחרים.
לא כל כך. אוקיי. פרדיגמה מאוד נפוצה. החל מתחילת השימוש במודלים האלה, כאמור,
סדר גודל של 2017 2018 שאומרת אני אקח מודל שהוא מודל שפה או משימות אחרות דומות למיתוג שפה שאפשר לעשות עם לייבל טקסט.
אני אאמין מודל עבורם. בשביל זה יש לי המון המון Data. אני אצור מודל טוב עבורם ואז אני אשתמש ב free train במודל הזה כדי להיות בסיס לסופר ווייז Training.
על בסיס דאטה מתוקן אנחנו מיד נראה איך זה נראה, איך זה נראה בצורה יותר מדויקת.
אז זה בעצם עובד כך אנחנו לוקחים מודל שפה?
כן. או משהו אחר שמסוגל לחזות מילים חסרות בטקסט או המשכים של משפט או משהו מהסוג הזה.
משהו שאפשר לעשות עם הלייבל טקסט. מזינים לו המון המון המון טקסט עושים רולינג, מוציאים כל מה שאפשר.
בדרך כלל גם החברות. נכון, החברות הגדולות כיום משתמשות במה שמותר להשתמש ובמה שאסור להשתמש, ולא כל כך משנה כל נכנס ביחד לתוך המשפך.
ואנחנו יכולים לאמן איתו מודל שפה. נעשה עבודה כמה שיותר טובה שם ולחזות את הלייבל טקסט החסר.
ועכשיו הדבר הזה ישמש לנו לאתחול של הפרמטרים של המודל.
אוקיי, אז בעצם זאת הכוונה. ה pre training הזה הוא עכשיו כבר אנחנו לא מתחילים באתחול רנדומלי של המודל שלנו,
אלא אנחנו משתמשים במודל הזה כאתר חול של המודל של המודל שבו אנחנו רוצים להשתמש.
עכשיו יש לנו לייבל דאטה עבור המשימה הספציפית, כמו לא יודע מה לחזות האם מה יהיה בירת מדינה מסוימת או לחזות מה הפרדוקס של מילה בהקשר או מה
הניתוח התחבירי שלה ומה וואטאבר כן או איזה Identity יש שם ומאיזה קטגוריה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
ובשאיפה בגלל שהמודל אומן.
קודם כל Engage model ובגלל שכמות הדאטה כאן וגם לפעמים שולטים ב learning רייט כדי לקחת את זה בחשבון.
אבל הסיבה שזה נקרא fine tuning. השלב השני של האימון הסופר Voice Learning בעצם נקרא Fine Tuning.
בגלל שבדרך כלל כמות הדאטה פה היא הרבה יותר קטנה מכמות הדאטה כאן לפעמים גם ה learning rates הוא יותר קטן ולכן השינויים
הם כבר יחסית עדינים בפרמטרים ביחס לנפח פער בין האתחול הרדומים שהכנסנו אליו במשימה במשימה הראשונה בפרק Trending.
ואז מה שאנחנו מקבלים זה בעצם task specific model. אוקיי, אז אם תשימו לב זה יש פה משהו.
אולי טיפונת יכול לבלבל. כן, או על ככה בהתחלה עד שמתרגלים אליו קודם לכן.
נכון, חשבנו על feature extra action כמשהו שבעצם קורה כאיזשהו Pre Processing של הטקסט.
נכון, לקחנו את הטקסט, לקחנו את המילים, חישבנו איזשהם פיצ'רים.
זאת אומרת בגדול הפיצ'ר Function. נכון.
Feature function זה משהו שפשוט מוגדר. הוא לכאורה כן.
ברור שמודל הלמידה צריך לדעת ממנו, אבל כאילו זה לא אותה מכונה.
בעצם יש איזשהו מכונה של קטע feature fiction. היא מייצגת את הטקסט באיזשהו אופן, ואז מודל השפה צריך איכשהו למשקל את הדברים או למצוא איזשהו קלאסי.
פייר? כאן זה בעצם ביחד. כן, אנחנו מה שאנחנו אומרים זה אנחנו לוקחים מכונה אחת, תכף נראה.
אנחנו טיפה. אולי משנים אותה בסוף, אבל בגדול מכונה אחת מארגנים אותה בהתחלה ודרך מסוימת מנצלים את זה שהבעיה היא והיה מאוד לא קמורה ולכן יש תלות.
זאת אומרת הפרמטרים של האתחול של הפרמטרים מאוד הולך להשפיע על התוצאה,
בייחוד אם אנחנו דואגים שה learning rate לא יהיה כל כך גדול או שכמות הדאטה היא משמעותית יותר קטנה וכן הלאה.
אז בעצם הפרמטר הזה הולך להיות מאוד משמעותי לפרמטרים, ובעצם אנחנו פשוט ניקח את אותו מודל, את אותו feature function ופשוט.
עכשיו נאמן אותה בדרך אחרת שתהפוך אותה מסוג של feature function למודל עבור הבעיה הספציפית שאימנתי כשעשיתי עליה Supervision learning.
אוקיי, אז סך הכל טכנית זה פרדיגמה מאוד פשוטה. קונספטואלית אני חושב שיש פה משהו מעניין.
כן, על שאלות כן, כאילו, אבל הגדרנו בדיוק מה המשקולות הוא מדגים אצלינו ובאופן עקרוני בכולם.
את צודקת שיש גם מקרים כאילו גישות יותר מתוחכמות fine tuning שלא נוגעים בכולם אלא נוגעים רק בדברים מסוימים.
לא כל כך יהיה לנו זמן לדבר. אני לא חושב שנגיע לזה בקורס הזה. כן, לדוגמה, יש הרבה שיטות שכאילו פשוט מטעמי יעילות חישובית בדרך כלל.
אבל בגדול הפרדיגמה הבסיסית היא תמשיכי לאמן.
כן כן, הרעיון של זה דווקא כן אפשר איזושהי תנועה.
כן כן, בטח. אנחנו מתחילים עם האבסטרקטי ועוברים ל קונקרטי.
בסדר. טוב. אז מה ספציפית הולך לקרות בצורה טיפונת יותר קונקרטית?
שוב אנחנו עוברים מהתנהלות אבסטרקטית ליותר ויותר קונקרטית. נראה כמו דוגמה ספציפית ממש.
אז בוא נגיד שמה שיש לנו זה language model, כזה שיש לנוסחה עם code disorder model לצורך העניין.
אוקיי, אם יש לנו Encounter disorder model אז יכול. אז מה שאנחנו נעשה בדרך כלל זה encounter disorder model.
כן, הוא מקבל איזשהו אינפוט נכון? נגיד אולי איזשהו קונטקסט כללי שהוא תמיד קבוע אולי, או כאילו קבוע פר דוגמה ועוד.
אולי ההתחלה של ה output שאני עכשיו מייצר וכל פעם מנסה לחזות את המילה הבאה.
עשיתי לו בהתחלה פרי טריינינג באיזשהו אופן נגיד למשל לא יודע, נגיד, פשוט לא כל כך משנה מה.
אולי אולי כל מודל וזה רק משמש בשביל לתת מה include משמש כדי לתת Metadata מכל מיני סוגים?
מאיפה הוצאתי את המידע הזה? מתי או whatever?
זה לא כזה משנה. בהתחלה היה לו linear layer ו soft max על פני אוצר המילים.
נכון, כדי לחזות את המילה הבאה אני הולך פשוט לקחת את אותו מודל, לזרוק את החלק האחרון.
כן, את החלק שהופך את הייצוג הפנימי שלו להתפלגות על אוצר המילים.
נכון שזה המכפלה במטריצה והסוף Mounts ולשים שם מה שקוראים לפעמים Classification head.
בדרך כלל הכוונה היא ל Linear פלוס soft max.
אחר. אחר. למה? כי הרבה פעמים לייבלים אחרים נכון, אני לא בהכרח כבר רוצה לחזות מילה.
אולי אני רוצה לחזות part of speech.
כן, אם זה נאון עובר באוזן או אולי אני רוצה קטגוריה של Identity אם זה person או location או כן או Generation וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
ולפעמים אני רוצה גם להוסיף שם איזשהו NLP. כן, לא פשוט לעניין.
פילוסוף מקס אולי אני רוצה להוסיף שם עוד קצת פרמטרים חדשים כאלו, אבל בגדול זה הרעיון אז אז הפרדיגמה.
אז אם נסתכל עכשיו לאור, זה הפרדיגמה, היא אומרת. יש לנו language model.
אימנתי אותו. השתמשתי בו כ איתחול כמו שעשיתי שם.
זרקתי כנראה את הממש הקצה שלו.
הוספתי שם איזשהו מה שנקרא classification head, שזה כל דבר בין מטריצה ו Soft Max לאיזושהי רשת קטנה לכשעצמה.
עשיתי לו סופר ווייס Training וקיבלתי task specific. יפה.
עכשיו בואו נהיה עוד יותר קונקרטיים ונסתכל על אני חושב על ה Instance הראשון של הבעיה הזאת של הפתרון הזה, שהיה מאוד פופולארי.
הוא לא היה הראשון. אגב, קדם לברט Almog כן, יש שם כל רחוב סומסום.
אחרי זה עברו עליו ברד זה. בנץ בעברית. מי שצפה בתוכנית וכן ואל מול זה.
יש את הפנס האדום הזה. הוא כמו כרובי. מה שנראה לי טוב הוא חדש לחלוטין.
אה, הוא חדש יחסית. כן, הוא כמו כרובי בערך, אבל אדום לא נכנס מאוחר.
אה, הוא נכנס מאוחר? אוקיי. כן. אין שום קרום משום מה.
לא יודע בדיוק למה הם בחרו שמות. מה זה בדיוק fine?
אני חושבת בערך 2. אני חושבת לפני שלמדנו על זה.
אה כן כן כן. אוקיי, אז קצת אתם מכירים משם, נכון?
אוקיי, ומה הרעיון שלו? אז דבר ראשון ברט מבוסס על ה Transformer. ספציפית הוא מבוסס על ה transformer Encounter.
אוקיי, לא על disorder. רק אנחנו עכשיו מסתכלים רק על Scooter ואנחנו בעצם מאמנים אותו.
עושים לו פרי טריינינג בצורה שאני תכף אסביר.
אבל הרעיון הוא כזה הולך להיות איזשהו INPUT, המשפט שאותו אנחנו רוצים או המילה שאנחנו רוצים לייצג בתוך המשפט שבו היא נתונה או בתוך הטקסט שבו היא נתונה.
זה הולך להיות מוזן לאיזשהו Transformer Encounter. הדבר הזה הולך לייצר בעצם ה output שלו.
אנחנו נקרא ל output של ה של code.
אנחנו נקרא לזה עם Padding או אם אנחנו מייצגים הרבה מילים אז עם Padding של המילים הנתונות ומשם זה ייכנס לאיזשהו Linear וסוף Max לגודל אוצר המילים.
ותכף אני אסביר מה. אז הרעיון הוא בעצם לעשות משימה שנקראת mask language model.
כן, אני לא זוכר כמה בתרגיל התעמקתי בזה, אבל כך או כך אני אסביר מה היא אומרת.
Mask language Modeling מאוד דומה ל modeling, אבל במקום לחזות את המילה הבאה אני חוזרת.
אני חוזה את המילים הממושכות. אוקיי, אז מה הכוונה?
יש לי Token מיוחד שנקרא mask. אוקיי, מיוחד שונה לא?
המילה מהשכלה. Token מיוחד. האינפוט של המודל של mask language model.
הולך להיות משפט אם דברים מסוימים בו מנוסחים.
ולכל אחד מהדברים האלה. לכל אחד מהמסכים אנחנו נצטרך.
בעצם אנחנו נבקש מפרט או נאמן את ברט כדי לחזות מהי המילה החסרה, או למעשה מהי התפלגות המילים החסרות על סמך שאר מילות המשפט.
בסדר. אז למשל בדוגמא הזאת ותזכרו כל מילה היא בפני עצמה.
כן, זאת אומרת, אנחנו לא חוזים את ההתפלגות המשותפת על פני שלושת המילים.
כל מילה לכשעצמה היא רדוקציה לכשעצמה כשאר מנוסחות בעצם כל מה שמושך מלבד המילה הזאת נשארנו במוסך.
אז נגיד למשל, אם המשפט זה My dogs mask and like to mask the entire mask.
אז נגיד דיקציה של המילה הראשונה היא אולי תהיה Hungary בהסתברות 5 אחוז friendly בהסתברות 4 8.
Cut nice smart וכן הלאה.
וכן אוקיי כן, יש כמה משחקים בפועל יכולים להיות כמה משחקים בכל דוגמה.
כן כן, כל הדוגמאות, אבל אפשר להתייחס לזה כאילו זה שתי דוגמאות.
עד כדי זה שבדוגמה הזאת מופיעה עדיין המסקנה. כל דיקציה של המודל היא עבור MSC מסוים.
כלומר שאר הדברים שמבוססים נשארים במוסכים. לא ננסה לחזות אותם ביחד.
בדיקה של המספר שלי לא להסתמך על אפליקציה של הלמס.
לא, לא. אוקיי, זה לא התפלגות משותפת.
כן, זה אוקיי, יפה. איך מאמנים עכשיו?
נהיה עוד יותר קונקרטיים. איך מאמנים את המודל הזה?
אז בגדול הרעיון הוא הרעיון. הוא כזה נכון, יש לנו Encounter אתם כן, אנחנו זוכרים את הארכיטקטורה.
יש לנו משפט כן או איזשהו טקסט שנכנס לתוך Transformer Encounter.
נכון שמתחיל דו מיני Validation או whatever הוא מציעים Padding, שאחרי זה עובר מכפלה במטריצה לגודל,
הופך לגודל אוצר המילים ואז זה הופך Soft Max ואנחנו מקבלים התפלגות על פי אוצר המילים שמייצג את ההתפלגות שהמודל חוזה עבור המילה שנמצאת באותו אינדקס.
אז בואו נגיד שיש לנו את המשפט ג'ון Visit מדגסקר yesterday איך ייראה ה lost function lost function או איך ייראה האימון?
האם הוא נראה ככה? אנחנו נגרין. בכל טקסט בדרך כלל טקסטים יהיו קצת יותר ארוכים מאורך 4.
כן, זה רק לשם הדוגמה. אז אנחנו הולכים להגריל 15 אחוז מהתרגילים שהם ישבשו, שעליהם אנחנו נחשב Loss.
על הדיקציה שלהם נחשב Loss. יפה. 80 אחוז מהתוכן שדגמנו, כלומר 80 אחוז מה 15, כלומר 12 אחוז.
מהזה הולכים פשוט להיות מוחלפים ב mask בסדר עוד עשרה אחוזים.
כלומר אחוז וחצי מהמילים של הטקסט המקורי הולכים להיות מוחלפים ב אדום טורקיז באיזשהו Token אקראי, לא קשור ועוד.
עשרה אחוז, כלומר עוד אחוז וחצי מהתוכנית הכלליים נשארים אותו דבר.
אז בוא נניח עכשיו שאני מסמן את המשפט אחרי המיסוך, אחרי התהליך הזה שאני קורא לו מיסוך.
X פריים. כן, X נגיד היה מקור X prime.
אז מה שאני עכשיו עושה זה לוקח? נגיד שהקבוצה הזאת היא s. כן, הקבוצה של כל ה 15 אחוז טוקנים שבחרתי.
מה שאני מחשב הלוח שאני מחשב זה בעצם הקרוס אנטרופי לא של הממוצע על התור, על המילים שנמצאות בפוזיציות האלו.
אז מה הכוונה?
אז למשל, אם בדוגמה הזאת בחרתי את המילה מדגסקר, אוקיי, בתור נציגה של S את המילה מדגסקר אז בחרתי או להחליף אותה ב mask בשמונים אחוז מהמקרים.
אני החלפתי אותה ב mask. בעשרה אחוז מהמקרים החלפתי אותה ב of בעוד עשרה אחוז מהמקרים השארתי אותה פשוט מדגסקר.
אוקיי, עכשיו אני גם יודע מה המילה אמיתית.
אני יודע אם המילה האמיתית באמת הייתה מדגסקר או mask.
אני יודע שהייתה מדגסקר.
כן, אז אני יודע מה המילה אמיתית, אז אני יכול לחשב את הכוס האנתרופי לוס נכון את ההסתברות שהמודל נותן למילה האמיתית על פי ההתפלגות שהוא רוצה או עושה.
למעשה אני עושה ממוצע על כל S.
עכשיו בואו נחשוב. אז אוקיי, אז סך הכל נשמע הגיוני כי זה מה שמראש רציתי לעשות.
רציתי לפתור מין סוג של משימת קלוז. אז כן, אתם זוכרים קלוז מהבגרות באנגלית.
מי שלמד בישראל נכון מסתירים חלק מהמילים צריך יש קו, צריך להשלים אותם.
זה פחות או יותר אותו דבר. אבל כפי אבל במשימת הקלוז הרגילה שלכם, שנכון שקיבלתם לא התבקשתם גם לפעמים לחזות לגבי מילה.
האם זאת באמת המילה שהייתה אמורה להיות שם או שזו סתם מילה אקראית שגרמתם?
נכון? ואנחנו כן מבקשים מברק לעשות את זה.
נכון, אנחנו כן מבקשים לעשות את זה. אולי ננסה לחשוב למה?
מה? אולי יכול? שוב, זה הכל אינטואיציות. כן, זה למה לא.
פשוט עשינו קלוז טסט רגיל שפשוט מאה אחוז היינו בוחרים 15 אחוז מהתרגילים ממסכים אותם.
נכון, זה יפה לחשוב על הערים הגדולות, אבל הסיפור כאילו נידון למוות כמעט אבסורדי.
וכמובן גם מה מוזר ומה קורה בכל הארץ שעושים את זה לא טוב.
אבל הסיפור של להשאיר חלק מהם ללא מס זה נורא מוזר.
זה לא רק את. אז להשאיר זה פשוט כדי שיהיה מקרה שבו כדי שהוא לא.
כדי שהוא ילמד לזהות כאילו רנדום כאילו זה בעצם שני הדברים האלה.
הם קצת הולכים ביחד. אתה מקבל איזושהי מילה, יש שם מילה בהתחלה ויש שם התפלגות בסוף בחלק מהמקרים זה בדיוק אותה מילה,
ולכן אתה רוצה למקסם פשוט את ההסתברות של האינפוט, ובחלק מהמקרים אתה רוצה לזנוח אותה ולמקסם הסתברות שמילה אחרת שהייתה אמורה להיות שם.
אוקיי, עכשיו למה אתה עושה את ה Correction הזה בניסיון לתקן?
אז בעצם הרעיון הוא שאתה שהיינו רוצים עם Padding, שעל סמך עם Padding הזה אנחנו חוזים את המילה החסרה?
אוקיי, שבעצם הוא גם מקודד מידע על ההקשר. אוקיי, כלומר מה סביר או לא סביר להופיע שם.
שזה בעצם סוג של מידע על ההקשר. אבל חלק, אבל בחלק מהמקרים נכון, כמו נגיד עם המילה מדגסקר.
אין לזה באמת תשובה נכונה. נגיד, תחשבו שאתם עכשיו הייתם ניגשים לבגרות באנגלית והיה מופיע לכם close והיה כתוב שם ג'ון visit yesterday.
כנראה שהייתם די מתעצבנים. נכון, כאילו זו לא שאלה הוגנת.
אולי אם היו שואלים אותי האם זה מדגסקר או אוב זה נשמע כמו שאלה סבירה, נכון לקלוז, אבל פשוט מה המילה החסרה?
לא יודע. אז כן, הייתי רוצה שזה ייצג את בעצם שזה ייצג את האינטלקט.
זה בעצם הרעיון שזה ייצג גם את ההקשר, אבל גם את האינפוט.
כן, כן. אז במילים אחרות, שהוא ידע שהוא גם ידע להיות auto encounter כשצריך.
כן, כלומר לקבל מדגסקר לחזות. מדגסקר גם ידע להיות דינוזאור.
כן, כי כשמכניסים לו סתם איזו מילה לא קשורה פה. הגיון Vision of yesterday.
אולי הוא לא החזיר מדגסקר כי יש עוד הרבה מקומות שאפשר לבקר בהם, אבל לפחות הוא לפחות הוא יבין שזה לא טוב.
בסדר, לפחות תיתן למדגסקר הסתברות יותר גבוהה. מליאור נגיד אוקי וגם ידע לפתור את הקלאץ.
אוקיי, אז בעצם אנחנו רוצים משהו שייצג גם את ההקשר, אבל גם את הזהות של המילה עצמה שהכנסנו.
בהינתן שהיא לא סותרת את הכן את ההקשר בצורה שלא ניתן ליישב ביניהם או שמאוד קשה ליישב, אז זה פחות או יותר הרעיון.
בסופו של דבר זה נפנופי ידיים. כן, זה אינטואיציה, אבל זה פחות או יותר האינטואיציה פה מאחורי זה.
ועכשיו מה שאני עושה זה בעצם ב insurance. אני פשוט מכניס את המשפט ומייצר את ה Embed.
אוקיי, אז זה מאוד חשוב. Difference כן בעסק.
מה שאני רוצה לעשות ניזכר. אני רוצה לעשות קונטקסט. אני רוצה לייצג מילה בתוך ההקשר.
אני רוצה לתת וקטור לכל אחת מהמילים האלו שמייצג.
את. את המילה בהקשר שלה. נכון את זה במדגסקר.
פה זה כנראה שם של מדינה ולא שם של סרט.
ושגיא מסר די פה זה שם של זה תיאור זמן ולא שיר של הביטלס ושל שג'ון פוס.
לא יודע מה אותו ג'ון ספציפי שדיברתי עליו במשפט הקודם.
נגיד זה טקסט יותר נכון כן, משהו כזה. אז בעצם אני רוצה לייצג גם את המילה וגם את ההקשר.
אני לא רוצה לפתור באמת את בעיית הקלוז אפ, כי זו לא הייתה המטרה שלי.
כל המטרה מראש היה פשוט לקודד את המילה ואת ההקשר שלו.
אז זה אנחנו עושים במין דרך כזאת שמאפשרת לנו.
כלומר, אני אומר כדי לפתור את הבעיה הזאת אני צריך לדעת די הרבה דברים על טקסט.
אני צריך לדעת לזהות מילים שנמצאות לא במקום. בשביל זה אני צריך להבין מה החוקיות של הטקסט, כי אחרת לא הייתי יכול לזהות את זה.
אני צריך לדעת להבין מה המילים החסרות. כן, כי שוב, אם לא הייתי מבין את הטקסט או לא יודע כל מיני דברים, היה לי קשה לעשות עם זה.
לפעמים צריך להבין את הדקדוק כי אחרת אני סתם מכסה דברים לא קשורים.
כל הדברים האלה למדתי מהפרי טריים. עכשיו מה שאני יכול לעשות זה לעשות את זה fine tuning.
כלומר, סיימתי את הפרי training במקום עכשיו לחזות את המילה החסרה.
אני מפעיל את זה על איזושהי משימה כמו Named entity recognition near ואולי משימה שזה איזשהו data set
שפעם היה פופולרי סקוואט או data set אחר Mali לא כזה משנה איזושהי משימה ספציפית שאני רוצה לפתור.
כן לזהות שמות, לזהות פרטים, להגיד מה כן Fusion sharing, לענות על שאלות, לדעת מה נובע ממה או כל משימה אחרת.
יש לה את הלייבלים שלה. אני אקח טוטו ברט, אני אזרוק את הקצה ויחליף אותו.
Classification Head בעצם עבור המשימה הספציפית לפי ההתאמה. אם כן, אז למשל דוגמה.
עוד יותר קונקרטית נגיד Party speech testing. כן, אז הרבה פעמים part of speech staging.
כשמשתמשים בשיטות האלה. מסתכלים על זה לא כבעיה של structure production, אלא כבעיה של אינדיפנדנט פרודקשן.
כן, לא תמיד, אבל הרבה פעמים כן, פשוט בגלל שהייצוג הפיצ'רים שלי הוא הרבה יותר חזק.
So I can get away with it. לא להשתמש ב production אלא ב independent production ואז שוב.
אז כן, הרעיון הוא בדיוק אותו רעיון.
יש לי את, את Burton קודר.
כן, את הבית Direction על Transformers Recorder עשיתי לו pre training בצורה זו או אחרת.
כן, כנראה בצורה שדיברנו עליה קודם. או איזושהי וריאציה על אותם רעיונות?
עכשיו אני מבין את המשפט הזה. מייצג כל מילה בהינתן שאר המילים ועושה את זה כמה פעמים כמה שכבות.
עכשיו בשאיפה יש לי ייצוג שעשה the same דיגיטציה למילה.
על ידי זה שהוא מסתכל על מילים אחרות וכן הלאה וכן הלאה. אז אם הברט עשה את תפקידו מספיק טוב, אולי אני כבר לא צריך structure production.
אני כבר לא צריך CRM או משהו כזה. כל מה שאני צריך זה ללכת לקחת את הווקטור שקיבלתי.
את I לבנות לו איזה Classification head קטן.
כן, אולי אפילו סתם לי נייר סופט מקס או אולי עוד קצת לעשות סופר ווייס training על ה speech text data כדי
גם לאמן את הדאבל הזה וגם לעשות קצת fine Tuning של הבית Direction על Transformer in Order של אוורט.
וזהו. לי פרדס שטייגר. כן כן, זה מעניין גם את המודל הזה, גם את המשקולות שאני מספיק מעליו.
בדרך כלל כן. בדרך כלל כן. יש לנו תמיכה בפורמט פופולרי.
בורגר לפחות מספיק. לא לקח הרבה זמן להכניס אותו פנימה.
כן, אפשר לעשות את זה וגם אפשר לעשות. אנחנו לא ניגע בזה בקורס כאן, אבל אפשר גם לעשות craft על גבי זה.
זאת אומרת, אפשר בסופו של דבר גם להגיד שמה שהברזל עושה זה מייצר לי בעצם פיצ'ר Function.
ועכשיו הפיצ'ר Function הזה אמנם כבר לא Generally Defined הוא אבל בסדר.
וזה נקרא noir על craft. לפעמים קוראים לזה וזה עובד הרבה פעמים יותר טוב מאשר רק נוירולוג.
פשוט א. זה נהיה. יש עניינים של טרנדים.
כן, זה נהיה קצת פחות טרנדי בזמן האחרון, אז פחות אנשים מכירים אותו, וגם אם אני מכיר אותו שלך מספיק טוב,
אז כבר הדלתא שלך היא בדרך כלל יותר קטנה, ואז אתה צריך לחשוב אם שווה לך להתעסק בזה בכלל.
אבל מן הסתם במקרים שבהם יש יותר data scar city כאילו שיש פחות לייבל data,
הייתי מניח שמנסים לעשות בו שימוש כמה שיותר טוב ואז באמת יכול להיות שכן ישתמשו בזה.
אוקיי. בסדר. עכשיו עוד דבר ככה זה מין הערה קטנה.
אני לא יודע אם אנחנו כן. אנחנו כבר. כן.
בסדר, אני עוד אספיק את זה. ואז אני חושב נסיים, זה ככה.
הערה קטנה Birds הרבה פעמים בעצם רוצים להשתמש ב bird לא רק כדי לקבל Embedded ובעקבות זה אפליקציה של מילים בתוך הקשר, אלא לפעמים של טקסט שלם.
אוקיי, ואז יש כאן איזושהי בעיה טכנית קלה או איזשהו אתגר.
נגיד, זה לא בהכרח בעיה של אתגר טכני קטן עם זה שבסופו של דבר הלברטל, Transformer Encounter הוא מוציא עם Padding לכל מילה בהקשר.
אבל אם אני רוצה לחזות משהו שהוא על כל המשפט מה אני עושה, אז כאילו הייתי עדיין יכול לאמן Classification head על המילה ה 17.
בסדר. זה אפשרי כי גם המילה 17 מסתמכת על כל שאר המילים האחרות בשכבות קודם.
יכול להיות שעדיין הייתי מצליח, אבל זה מכניס איזשהו Bias מסביר למה 17, 16, 15?
מה? כי לא זה. אז כדי לפתור את הבעיה הזאת עושים שכלול קטן שזה מוסיפים לזה.
כן, קוראים לזה פעם calls token. מין כאילו מין דמי Token כזה שמה שנכנס אליו זה פשוט תמיד נכנס אליו איזשהו Token מיוחד שנקרא CLS.
אוקיי. והרברט עצמו.
הוא לא עושה איתו שום דבר. מזין מקבל CLS פולט CLS.
זה סתם. כן. לא קורה שם שום דבר מעניין. אבל ב fine tuning מה שעושים זה בעצם עושים עליו את הסמים עליו את ה lost.
כן, אם רוצים לעשות פיקציה של כל הטקסט ואז זה מנקודה ניטרלית כזאת שעדיין יכולה להסתכל על זה, עדיין מסתכלת על כל הטקסט כמובן כי זה self attention.
כן? אז כל Token מסתכל על כל התרגילים האחרים, אבל זה שובר את הסימטריה הזאת.
לפעמים גם עושים לה CLS הזה pre training, כלומר גם משהו שהוא self supervision.
אז נגיד למשל, אז משימה שמשתמשים בה זה next sentence addiction.
משימה קצת טיפשית. כאילו נותנים שני משפטים, שני משפטים שהם עוד סוג של משפטים עוקבים בטקסט או סתם שני משפטים מהקורס שלכם,
ואתם צריכים להגיד כאילו הפיקציה היא האם אלה שני משפטים סמוכים או סתם שני משפטים שלקחתם מהטקסט?
כן, זה אולי מועיל למשהו לפעמים.
אז כאילו אם תראו מה זה ACLS או כן או מה זה הספר או הוא כן הספר או הוא כן זה.
אם רוצים להכניס עוד ספיישל Token שבעצם מפריד בין משפט לבין המשפט הבא.
אם אתם רוצים להזין זוג כן אתם רוצים. לפעמים אתם רוצים לעשות פיקציה של זוג משפטי, לא של משפט, אז אתם מוסיפים עוד ספיישל Token של set.
בקיצור, יש כל מיני וריאציות ורעיונות מאוד דומים, כל מיני וריאציות כדי לאפשר לעשות פיקציה,
לאו דווקא למילים, אלא למשפטים או לזוגות משפטים או לכל מיני דברים מהסוג הזה.
עושים סנטימנט analysis למשל עם CLS Token ואז נגיד חוזים חיובי או שלילי.
זו דוגמה אחת שנתקלנו בה. אפשר לעשות גם הרבה דוגמאות אחרות.
בגדול, מה שאנחנו ראינו הכניסה של מאז הכניסה של ברט זה שמשתמשים בו.
א. השתמשו בו בטירוף. כן, זאת אומרת, הוא הפך.
הוא הפך להיות הדבר הראשון שאתם מנסים, פחות או יותר בכמעט כל בעיה שבה יש לכם באותו דומיין Building Order.
כן, זה הפך להיות משהו שהוא לגמרי סטנדרטי בכמעט כל בעיית NLP, וזה קרה מאוד מהר.
עכשיו אנחנו נמצאים כנראה משהו כמו חמש שנים. שש שנים אחרי שהוא באמת, הוא התחיל להיות very bad ועדיין רואים אותו בשימוש.
מי שמתעניין יכול להסתכל יותר לעומק בבר פייפר. זאת לא הטכנולוגיה הכי עכשווית עליה נדבר בשבוע הבא, אבל זה בהחלט.
Something to consider. כן, זה לא זה לא זה.
זה משהו שעדיין נמצא בארגז הכלים ולפעמים זה הדרך.
זה הדרך הטובה ביותר להתקדם. על הטכנולוגיה שנמצאת בחזית, אולי צעד אחד מאחורי חזית המחקר מדבר בשילוב.
אז טוב, להתראות. תודה רבה.
רבה. אני לא יודע למה.
אתה. מתכוון למשל אני עושה עבודה טובה.
אני לא. מדבר על.
כסף, אבל זה לא עניין של. מה?
אני? צריך?
לעשות? את זה?
זה לא משהו. עם שובו בנים אתה יכול למצוא משהו חדש.
אפשר לצאת לחופשת? חורף?
הלאה. הכתבה הקודמת.
פורסם עי מערכת שבת. מה אתם אומרים שיכולים לבחור לעשות בסופו של דבר כמה שלבים.
כן נכון לעכשיו אני עושה את זה איך שאני אוהב את הסקירה שלי.
אמרת שבערך לא מזמן התקשר אליו בכל זאת, בעצם הוא מייצג את הלמידה ביותר בהקשר של ישראל.
כמו כן, זה קשור לאאוטפיט של האינקה.
אמר כי לדעתו כדי לחזות את העתיד מספק אולפנים לעתים קרובות מדי עבור בעיות באמריקה עוד לפני כן.
אז. אתה יודע, אתה לא יודע, זה נראה כמו הנקודה שכאילו אתה אומר.
זה בעצם הרעיון שדיברנו עליו בהקשר של ספילברג, וזה טוב יותר בשיווק.
כיצד יש בסרט החדש של ישראל? חבל שאני אתה יודע שכולם ייהנו.
מעצבן אז. אז אם אתה רוצה, אפשר גם לדבר על זה בשיעור הבא, כי מבחינת שמעון יכול לדבר על זה,
לכתוב על זה האינטואיציה או האינטואיציה אומרת כדי לפתור את הבעיה הזאת צריך לדעת כל מיני דברים על כל מיני דברים שכן, כי אחרת אתה לא תדע לפתור.
באמת שבכל מה שקשור אז אתה צריך לדעת גם להבין וגם לדעת פרטים עובדתיים וגם לדעת וואטאבר.
על מה נפוץ לדבר, על מה אנשים לרוב חושבים שמקובל לדבר עליו או לא.
מדובר פה בשביל לדבר עליו בסנטימנט ולא יודע.
כי לפעמים הדברים האלה יעזרו לך לעשות. אם יש לך מודל מספיק טוב, יש יותר מספק, יש מודל?
אולי הוא עושה Feature אקסטרה של טוב בשביל כל מיני.
מה זה פיצ'ר מספר פיצ'רים שאתה רואה כשאני חושב עליו, אבל בעיני זה פיצ'ר חדש.
בארהב התמונה צולמה עבור מודל של מודל עסקי.
אתה יכול לדעת. זה נפוץ לתקשורת בין אישית.
בזכות הארכיטקטורה שלו, אבל זה כן לפנות אליכם אם אתה אומר כן או לא יודע אם הוא יודע לעשות פסטלים ומאוזנים מספיק טוב שאתה אומר,
אז כנראה שעיצוב הפיצ'רים שלו הוא כזה שהוא יודע לעשות הרבה דברים, לא הופעות.
כן, הוא מבין איפה הבעיות?
למה יש כל כך הרבה טוב? מילים ומשפטים זה בדיוק מה מופיע עם מה לוקח את זה.
יאללה, להגיד שאחרי סן פרנסיסקו זה כל מיני דברים כאלה.
כן, זה צריך, זה האינטואיציה. כן, אתה יודע, זה לא כל כך חכם אז זה בסדר, זה פשוט לא נכנסנו לבפנים שלהם Coding איך הוא עושה את זה?
אלה לא דברים שצריך לדבר וזה ממש ממש טוב.
בלי הדיכאון הוא פשוט בדיכאון החוצה. הוא עושה מספיק בשביל להתחיל פשוט מהאמצע.
שם את הווקטורים האלה גונבים את הנקודות. כן, לפני שהוא סיים קולפים אותו.
כן, הייתי רק מטופלת Cns.
למה לא להשתמש בערך כל התוכנית בלי לעשות את המרב שאפשר, אבל זה לא תמיד רעיון טוב.
יכול להיות שעובד שאתה יודע עבד שמאוד מלחיץ את הסביבה.
נכון, יכול להיות שכאילו מגיע לך סיגנל במימדים מסויימים אבל תבצע אותם הרבה דברים אחרים.
אבל יש לך מושג. הרעיון לשים את זה שהוא מקבל את כל האינפורמציה.
כמעט כולם מקבלים את כל האינפורמציה, אבל הוא לא בא לשם.
המשמעות בדיוק אז הוא מקבל את האינפורמציה של כל המקרים. על בסיס זה אפשר לדעת בדיוק, והוא לא משמש גם כן לייצג מידע.
זה לא מסוכן? זה? בדיוק מה שהבנתי הוא עדיין קצת בסדר.
רק הפתיח הראה מה היה בדרך של פרק באופן קיצוני בבוקר.
צריך להגדיר את זה קצת, כאילו היה מדובר על זה.
די קשה להבין שכל לימודי שפה של קורת גג שלא מגדלים בשבת.
אנחנו מסתכלים כל משחק. שערך התפקיד שלנו בעצמו.
דיברנו על חדשנות. בתוך הבית.
לא הבנתי. את הבית.
אבל. אני הייתי רוצה להציע רשימת טקסט.
לפני שנתחיל קצת, מה לעשות? כן, כמו שאני מבין בתקופה האחרונה הגרפיקאי מתכנן ואז על השולחן כנראה יש המון המון המון דאטה לעשות מאפס.
עד כמה שהפילטר עם סמסונג גלקסי S3 זה. בסדר.
נראה מה יהיה לנו להמשיך לכתוב פה. בניילון נצמד.
כאילו. אורך 5 דקות לפחות זה שווה את זה?
לא בא לך להירשם? עכשיו בתי ספר זה לא כל כך בבית כי לא חושב שאתה עושה את זה, אבל אין לי הרבה דברים מבוססים.
על שיעורי בית בעסקים במקומות ציבוריים במזרח התיכון.
כמו כן ברור מה קורה אפשר להגיד זה כמעט הכל.
אתה הולך בדרך הנכונה. למה?
כי עשיתי לא רע בכלל.
לא פשוטים, אבל גורמים רבים במדינת ישראל צריך לדעת לקרוא את הכתבה.
החמישית ומה שאתם כותבים על משכנתא כדי להראות בסוף זה כסף.
לא בטוח שזה טוב, אבל אין לי תירוץ.
לא צריך לדעת איפה זה מתחיל.
לא הרגיש לי הרבה זמן, לא ראיתי הרבה זמן, לא היה הרבה זמן, לא יצא הרבה זמן.
סבבה. נשמע כאילו מה לא בסדר.